tragic news today to our brothers and
sisters across the pond our good allies
over to the united kingdom our
condolences rest in peace to the queen
who passed away and you know that being
said i know it's a tragic day and i'm
i'm already getting triggered myself
because instantly you see woke leftists
coming out and insulting and spitting on
the memory of talking about dancing on
the grave of the queen and it's just
have you no decency and they don't they
revel in the pain and suffering of their
symbolic enemies and others and people
they hate and that's that's the thing
that really bums me out look
i was obviously no fan of john mccain i
did not revel in gloat when he died and
a lot of people i know did a lot of
friends i uh friends of mine did and i
get it it's just not for me i'm not you
know we had that that tweet from the
libertarian party of new hampshire the
other day showing megan mccain crying
over her father's coffin and they and
i'm just like that
sickens me dude the queen was
one of the most famous notable figures
powerful prominent loved respected uh
figures in history and uh
she passed away and it's unsurprising
now that there are people who are
reveling and gloating so it's gross but
we're gonna talk about that because i
think it i think it shows a donation
between you know who we are and who they
are and at least trying to have some
decency and respect for those who may be
suffering or grieving we have other news
a democrat has been arrested for
murdering a journalist which is kind of
kind of surprising because i was told
donald trump was the one who was going
to inspire maga republicans to harm
journalists but here we go it's like
there's the story and then in dc an
emergency has been declared
because of the migrants that are being
sent in and it's really funny and
hypocritical that the sanctuary city is
upset that they're a sanctuary city how
about that before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com and
become a member if you would like to
support our work as a member you'll get
access to the timcast irl uncensored
show we'll have that coming up for you
at about 11 p.m tonight where we talk
about things that aren't so
family-friendly and not so
we'll just say uncensored so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us to talk
about all of this and more is ali beth
stuckey hello
thanks for having me absolutely who are
who are you
who am i i host a podcast called
relatable on blaze tv monday through
thursday we talk about culture politics
news theology from a christian
conservative perspective i wrote a book
called you're not enough and that's okay
escaping the toxic culture of self-love
and i do a few other things as well are
you have you announced your next book
yet or no i have not announced my next
book but it's in the works all right
right on thanks for joining us we also
have hannah claire brimelow hi i'm
hannah claire brimlow i'm a writer for
timcast.com
yeah i'm simple enough that's it
hardcore
i uh for i'm ian crossland what's up
dudes good to see allie um i want to
talk about the queen but let's start the
show before we do because that's
probably our leading story is it it's
the queen yeah yeah we'll get rock and
roll in there lydia what's happening
yeah for sure i'm excited to talk about
the queen especially since i was so
grossed out by the libertarian party of
new hampshire's tweet about john oh man
like that either i think we're better
than them we can act better that's muted
right yeah once muted okay cool we're
good to go well let's let's jump into
the first story the tragic news
from the daily mail have they no shame
woke liberals writing for the new york
times new york magazine and the atlantic
waste no time attacking the colonizer
queen mere hours after her death age 96
and hours after twitter took down
vilepost mocking monarch now i don't
know if i i don't know why that tweet
got removed we should probably look into
it before i make my opinion but i don't
think you should be censored for having
bad opinions i'm glad we get to see
these people being awful because i i
don't i don't want to you know
mistakenly
work with associate with people who
would do something like this
so they write the death of the of queen
elizabeth has been celebrated by some
opinion riders with one promising to
dance on her grave and another
describing her 70 year reign as
devastating while millions around the
world were mourning the death of the 96
year old provocateurs were within hours
of her death mocking the outpouring of
grief in some of the most esteemed
publications in the united states one
pennsylvania professor even said she
hoped the queen's final hours of pain
would be excruciating
yeah i don't think that was the case
you're an awful person jeff bezos was
among those condemning her now deleted
tweet good i'm glad to see it and uh
it's nasty stuff man
it's tough i i think what we're seeing
here is that these people will say
anything for woke points
and so
they know they're gonna be contrarian
they know shock content is going to get
them attention and here they are now
getting it so i won't get into you know
their names or whatever but just point
out like
there are people in this world and in
this country that are just
evil despicable they revel in suffering
and pain there's a lot to say about the
monarchy we're starting to debate you
know the issues of monarchy whether or
not there is one after this because i
know you know what i'm saying king
charles i know he's he's assuming
but is he really
i mean he's already very old
but uh i don't know what do you guys
think about uh the woke stuff let's get
into that first
yeah well it's not really surprising i
feel like every time a politician or a
person dies that people on the left have
deemed an oppressor whether it's true
direct oppression or not
they think that they are more virtuous
by kind of celebrating that person's
death i don't think that they just think
that it's not bad to do it i think they
actually think that is moral and good
because to them they see themselves as
kind of
you know
on the right side of history and someone
like queen elizabeth as a white
colonizer and oppressor and therefore
why wouldn't you celebrate her death in
the same way that she would celebrate
hitler's death of course i don't think
that's comparable at all i don't think
that she can be compared to hitler or
any other true oppressor in any way but
it's not surprising it's what they
always do so they did the john mccains
which they did too
george bush that's what they did to
barbara bush i mean it it doesn't matter
that's what they're gonna do i think the
queen is particularly vulnerable to this
because americans have no comparable
figure to the monarchy
that's complicated but uh you know i
everyone in our office is tired of me
saying this but i'm british i'm a
british citizen and an american citizen
and it is
the
true divide between what i feel like is
my like
upbringing in america and my british
heritage which is that the monarchy is
an institution that represents not only
political power but a cultural history
that is so interwoven with things that
are challenging for the british people
as well as things that are make them
unique and prosperous and i think
queen elizabeth in so many ways
partially because her tenure was so long
she reigned for 70 years there's really
no one like her and during her time you
have to remember all of the social
cultural and technological chains that
swept through england there's really no
one like her and i know you know when
did the reign of the british monarchy
end there's a lot of points in history
where people will say like well this is
really effective and this is really
effective and to me and to a lot of
people that i know
this is the end of the british monarchy
because she represents a tie to a
history that is so far gone from the
culture we have today see harry is it
harry that left with meghan markle is
that harry he was basically done with
monarchy you know at some point it
becomes a burden she became uh in line
for the throne when her uncle
uh resigned and he said i don't want to
be king i'd rather marry this american
and
at the time he couldn't marry her and
also be king so he renounces the title
her father became the king and then she
became the heir to the throne i mean
monarchy has always been to a certain
degree optional you don't have to take
over the role there's i think british
culture you see it a lot in the in the
obituaries that are coming out right now
for queen elizabeth which is that she
had a very strong sense of duty and the
idea of a sense of duty at least in the
way i was raised and the ties that i saw
to my british heritage was like this is
a big theme the idea that you rise to
your purpose and you rise through it and
you serve you know and i think in a lot
of ways though there are things wrong
with the monarchy and i think it's
important to be able to criticize your
government
queen elizabeth really represented that
to people and even though there are
people who don't support the monarchy
they don't love it they will still mourn
this loss because it is the end to an
era of british history and british
culture yeah the british empire she
technically she was the empress um until
about what this says 97 when when what
is that hong kong was seeded over to
china again uh that was when the british
empire ended so that's when she no
longer was the empress of course you
could be a king and an emperor at the
same time the king of england the empire
of britain and she's still the effective
head of government in canada i mean she
doesn't really do anything she was still
the effective head of government i think
in australia again those countries
operate independently but she has such a
serious cultural influence that i really
think you know there are lots of
wonderful things about america but that
aspect we don't have and we chose not to
we separated from england for a reason
and i think those things are good but
it's really difficult for americans to
understand because we view our political
leaders with a level of vitriol and we
know they are temporary we know if we
fight hard enough we can push them out
and that's just not how
you know this works i mean he's a
unifying figure even for people on the
left and the right in britain it seems
like a lot of people unified them yeah
or unified around her yeah and i think
part of it is you know yesterday she met
with liz trust who's the new prime
minister she to the end was conducting
business and is such an integral part of
culture in culture and uh the
administrative state of britain you know
we really just don't have anything like
that do you think that because the the
royal family what was that sorry nothing
do you think that because they know
they're like they're in for life they
try to do a better job of being unifying
as opposed to the politicians here no
they're going to be hated so they're
like i'm out screw you well i think
that's part of their nature that they're
not supposed to be political she really
didn't comment on politics and really
none of them do except for meghan markle
because she's not interested in that
royal title of being a unifier at all
yeah i'm not a fan no no of marvel of
markle or royalty oh okay yeah i mean
royalty has its problems yeah but um you
know i can look i don't i'm not british
i'm not from the united kingdom so if
people there really love her i'm kind of
like you know i don't know what you're
thinking we don't have a queen we got
rid of that royalty i think it's
horrific it's it's if you're born into a
family you get to run the country makes
no sense it's the opposite of
meritocracy it has no no basis in a
functional reality or a system of merit
of human merit but that being said the
first thing i thought when the queen
died was
i i was thought of her family and how
they're emotional how they're handling
it right now
then the second thing was
when you asked me when i everyone looked
at me when i walked in and was like so
what do you think about the queen
and i was like i you know i'd rather
that the monarchy ended and that she
lived then that she died and there's
still a monarchy i i have no problems
with her she actually seemed like a
pretty cool person from a distance from
the western media that i was getting my
whole life seemed like one of the best
you know monarchs in human history
personally you know she was very open
well loved and remember she served with
15 prime ministers and 14 american
presidents so and as far as i know no
one doesn't like her think about
everything that you've seen as a 96 year
old think about everything you want to
remember when she was coordinated her
the first prime minister she worked with
was winston churchill which is just like
to put that in perspective who was born
in like 1847 maybe like i can't remember
she was like old when i was born i was
thinking about that there are british
people or generations of rich people
where she has always been the queen
she's not just on your money she is
always around well and i think because
the world is so chaotic and because
things in the world and especially in
the uk have changed so much her steady
presence has really kind of helped keep
people sane and now that she's gone
what's gonna happen
king charles what's king what's the king
gonna do
the king he's what's a king gonna do
they're like are they gonna put him on
all the money now they gotta they gotta
get some money and some stamps are there
like other kings on their money too or
is it all queen elizabeth prime minister
um i if i'm remembering correctly
different just like we do like with
coins in the dollar and whatever else
like we have different presidents on our
on our uh currency she's on some money
and she's on the stamp but
not all like canadian money too yeah
because she is the head of i mean those
were part of the british empire so she
is still
yeah to the story so ian was saying
she's the she's the empress and now the
emperor emperor is now reigning supreme
emperor charles is is back
technically the british empire is kind
of amorphous they never really said when
it ended everyone's just kind of like
yeah it just kind of ended when when
hong kong was in 97 they thought maybe
the suet loss of the suez canal was
really when the british empire
no longer had power maybe it just exists
you know du jour but not de facto just
like she is the figurative head of
government of canada or of like the
british virgin islands right like those
places all have their own governments
and elect their own officials and have
their own form of government it's kind
of in name only that they're still tied
to the empire the empire is not
functional as it once was i wonder how
long the the monarchy will last at this
point now because the way harry was just
like no man i'm done what i think is
that it'll end up going bankrupt i think
that the monarchy will always be sort of
part of because you also have to
remember we think of it as like oh it's
the queen and the prince and she's got
those grandkids but like actually there
are still dukes and duchesses and people
like there are all kinds of titles in
british columbia
like what would the dissolution of the
monarchy actually look like if it went
bankrupt what would happen
well
my thought is
it's very hard to
remove the monarchy entirely because
they would have to undo how they conduct
some governmental business right yeah
and so to a certain extent
there
will be enough people who don't
like who's this it's like
it's king charles now then it's william
and then it's george so that gives us
like what at least a hundred years
probably more yeah i think part of it is
that they will become less influential
and it becomes unlikely like i wonder if
they'll have to hold some other kind of
office their government will evolve well
it's not just enough to be granted this
power you have to have something else i
think you know charles got to bring it
back to their roots start issuing
letters of mark sending out naval
destroyers
private vessels to raid cargo ships
i think that would be fascinating bring
back colonization there we go but where
would he colonize that's well china's
colonizing mars
21st century colonization would you be
psyched about the monarchy if tomorrow
king charles is like i'm sending
something to them hell no it's got to be
done in a decentralized urban way where
we're all in it together because if we
start what's going to happen is
corporations
it's going to be corporations starting
to colonize it yeah and that's going to
be true yeah talk about a monarchy the
owner of the corporation while
while they're actively criticizing
colonization and they're like these
people china is actively colonizing
they're literally called
it is literal colonization
africa south america yep and even
australia and america and europe yeah
it's it's you know because their idea of
colonization is like they think white
people are evil yeah so they assume a
bunch of white people get on a boat and
they all have like devil horns and
pitchforks like now we're gonna go kill
other people yeah but in reality it was
like people saying there's not a lot of
land here anymore i'm gonna get in the
boat and go find a better place to live
they don't yeah
yeah so what's happening now with
colonization in china is that it's just
regular chinese citizens being like i'm
gonna move to the united states and go
live in new york i'm gonna live to move
to vancouver and then what happens is
large swathes of these populations move
into these areas they create you know
little uh cultural centers little
chinatowns and things like that and that
is literal colonization well it's a lot
more nefarious than not in places like
africa and south america the chinese
government is going in there and saying
oh you want a railway great you get to
you know pay us this amount of money
ethiopia can't pay them back for it oh
you're in debt to us now we own you so
it's not as much like creating chinatown
as hey we're going to
literally take over your country yes by
putting you in debt but i i just wanted
to differentiate between the evil vision
of colonization that they these these
woke leftists think versus
when you just have a large population
moving around and moving into places
yeah you're right they also have the
belt road initiative they're doing a
bunch of these these these deals like
you mentioned they are actively doing
oil exploration in africa and south
america they wanted to they wanted to
dig a nicaraguan canal yeah to compete
with panama there they are expanding
rapidly not to mention the south china
sea so you want to talk about modern
colonization maybe we can get some of
our friends over on the woke left to
criticize it but somehow i just don't
think they're going to do it they
usually criticize the
israeli colonization of the west bank
there's
when you talk about colonizing it could
be barren land people go and create a
colony there of people that's a form of
it but then there's also where you go
and seize someone's property and then
you set up your house there which is
also a form of colonization but they're
completely different really ethically
one of them you're not displacing humans
the other one is you're seizing people's
land so in in israel for instance
there's a lot and i get a lot of the
media through the western media so it's
hard to parse what's happening but i've
seen videos of people getting off of
buses like israelis with or or americans
that have been invited there to colonize
the west bank and they get off the bus
with like mattresses in their arms and
just run and they're all charging racing
to get to the house first where the
palestinian guy is not home and then
they take it they go in and they're like
this is my home now i don't mess with me
the police will will shoot you so you
this is where we took it yeah i'd want
to dig into that i think people have
talked about that and there's something
about that that i don't fully understand
yeah intentional and i don't think i
don't think like just jumping from china
to israel
the two biggest colonizers on earth
right now are the israelis and the
chinese that is one hundred percent not
well who then who's the other secretary
israel is so small how many people live
in israel yeah but
there's a billion and a half people in
china talk per capita they're colonizing
the west bank what else are they
colonizing
the west bank
but i'm talking per capita we're talking
we're talking about what percentage of
the population are colonizing right now
israel's yeah
i mean it's colonizing it's been causing
since thanksgiving
i mean i just don't know i wouldn't be
you know no but arguably
we're talking about one of the most
populous nations on the planet with a
billion and a half people
send having their citizens either freely
move or military expansion on every
continent on the planet even antarctica
to antarctica to a certain degree it's
just like there's no reason to bring up
israel in that context billion people
the two largest yeah come on no you
can't compare 1.3 billion to 8 million
yeah but you got to go per capita i'm
not talking about per capita per capita
it's very much you have much less
probably in china because there's so
many people and so few relative
colonizers i don't know what's this
obsession with israel you're talking
about like a nation obsessed with israel
right now you're like
hell bent on are you denying that
they're colonizing the west bank but
what does that have to do with
globalization colonizing wouldn't they
say that that was their land in the
first place that they were the first one
people there because they were
historically i'm not i don't even know i
don't know your argument i don't i
haven't seen the video i don't know the
evidence of what you're talking about i
would just be curious because i haven't
really heard about it the argument of
why it starts with what i think
if it's actually happening like where
else are they colonizing you look at
china they're all over the world
colonizing like where's israel going
right a lot of people i think consider
an ethical colonization because it's
internal but
you know
the population of new york city is like
what nine million people so it'd be like
are you comparing it to like if the
population of new york spread out across
the country is that colonizing you know
like if if a bunch of new yorkers
started going from manhattan to jersey
city i i went to florida and they were
like fighting and they were like rides
and stuff like it's bad but i just don't
know how you compare the size of
population to what china is doing i mean
it's not like israel is sinking you know
vietnamese shipping vessels firing uh
missiles over neighboring islands into
territorial waters of other countries
hamas and israel have been firing
missiles into each other's territory for
yes you're talking about a small
regional conflict that's a little
sequence yeah it is great compared to
china expanding in the south china sea
no i'm not comparing sending okay so
we're talking i guess there's a
comparison and that they're both
colonizing different maybe different
you're just saying like they're the
first and the second yeah the two the
two largest colonization programs on
earth right now are in gaza west bank
and the chinese i'm pretty sure that's
just not true that's a weird thing to
say
i wouldn't call what's happening in
israel like i i would say i feel like it
is yeah russia is probably the second
biggest colonizer and where in what
aspect they're invading right now
there's a military invasion yes and then
also just the expansion of like there's
more russian troops and people spreading
out than israeli
do you have that number somewhere bro
russia russia took crimea and now
they're that's another invasion though
it's different colonization is like not
military i mean i guess there's there's
fight there could be fighting okay bro
but i don't i don't i don't get the
point california is colonizing texas and
arizona and colorado i think new yorkers
are colonizing florida
left during covenant and they're like we
like it here we're going to stay and
bring everyone up i mean
it's it's a hard comparison to make i
understand what you're saying that there
is conflict there and it feels like one
force has more power than the other but
i do i wouldn't classify what's going on
in israel as colonization more than
regional israel was a british and french
colony at the end of world war one they
they promised the allied forces the
british french and um
uh italians promised that area to the
arabs if the arabs would betray the
ottomans so the arabs were like oh
you're going to give us this area that's
now israel you're going to give this to
the arabs then yeah we'll betray the
ottomans they betrayed the ottomans the
french and english won the war and then
they said you know what arabs we're
going to renege on our offer we're going
to keep the lamb for ourselves and then
they created the sykes pico agreement
and that basically
set up israel as we know it but it was
very small and then over the next 30 or
40 years i think
there was like a military buildup and
then all of a sudden in the what was it
the 50s i think they had the seven day
war was in 1957 1963 all around that
time
um and uh just conquered a lot of land
around it whether you want to consider
that colonization or not here's the
question is all
colonization wrong do you think
it's a good question you asked before
the show too
i don't i don't either there's there's
this romantic romanticizing it on the
left about like native americans for
instance
they
just they want to believe this narrative
of the evil white man from europe coming
and just massacring all the natives it's
like oh don't get me wrong there's a
bunch of really bad history there of
course yeah lands get conquered war
breaks out and some people win out over
others but it's like
i don't know man the aztecs were kind of
brutal you know they were warring with
each other they were sacrificing people
ripping out their hearts and stuff like
that so it's hard to say
you know but by based on our standards
as americans of the constitution the
answer is yes
if you think our standards are better
than other countries standards
so uh
you know hong kong for instance i think
you were mentioning this before the show
they had like it seems to be getting
really bad for them now with china
moving in because we don't we don't
think china's values are good values
they're authoritarian they they uh
let's just say the people who are who
are living there are not doing so well
you got the uh
the uyghur concentration camps so would
hong kong be better off with you know
western colonization i think the people
there
is yeah i think they would have thought
so i mean they're the ones that are
being thrown in jail for being
dissidents and so i would say that you
know they try to champion free speech
which are western values those are not
universal values so but i don't know
that the ins necessarily justify the
means in all of these cases but was hong
kong better off as a british colony 100
yeah imagine
what this country what the united states
would look like if
no one ever came here
i mean what would it be
i i can't imagine that it would be
substantially well developed well i
think leftists have this fantasy i've
noticed this they've got this like
romantic fantasy in their head
that before civilization things were
better that if we all went back to
living in tribes and just like living
off the earth and that we would be
better off than we were well than we are
now with civilization it is objectively
better to stub your toe and then die
from the infection right yes that's true
antibiotics are bad yeah exactly western
medicine for the win
pretty brutal they were there's tribal
chieftains ruled by force
i think we're insulated from brutality
in a certain extent to because of the
way we live now because of modern
conveniences i also think that
you know and i'm grateful for that i
don't want to say that i would prefer to
live in a more brutal time but i also
think that we are used to a certain
level of stability that was just not
true for most of global history i mean
all of the borders of countries that we
see now even if you don't like that they
were part of colonization they exist
because we went through a period of
exploration discovery i mean no one
today is going to get on a boat and be
like i'm going to find some land and see
what happens there like we can't do that
because we know what's out there you'd
be nice but you should go find an
uninhabited island in middle of nowhere
and be like i'm going to build this up
you know make something out of it i'm
going to turn it into something we can't
do that because it belongs to everyone
now because we've explored the world
like that time period is difficult for
us to relate to which i think helps feed
this narrative that colonization was bad
because we don't really know what life
was like while that was going on here's
here's the funny thing uh this is a
story i've told before about this woke
guy i was talking to north dakota
and uh he was at the dakota access
pipeline protest i said you know i have
to leave by tomorrow because i have a
meeting in los angeles and i got to
drive from north dakota to l.a which is
crazy not a meeting tomorrow but in a
few days so i got to leave tomorrow and
then uh he was like nah man you
shouldn't do that
meeting schedule that's colonial
thinking and then i was like what what
what does that mean he's like it's
colonial thinking man like like having a
meeting and a schedule the native
americans don't have that they like wake
up when they need to and they get to
work and they get it done and then i was
like
having a meeting is colonial thinking
like what are you saying like where what
does that mean like that i'm tracking
time it's like yeah like the colonizers
from europe came and they brought these
schedules in time yeah you know these
meetings and then i was like what are
you talking about dude like asians had
schedule have schedules too they're not
white people yeah in their minds
they think colonization is all modern
success and all modern success is bad
and i'm just like you're a white
supremacist with a guilty conscience yes
they attach everything that they don't
like to colonialism and white supremacy
like the gender binary there was this
like new york times article the other
day saying maternal instinct is a myth
that was created by like western men in
order to oppress women and i always go
back to like whether you believe the
bible is the inspired word of god or not
it is still a book that was written at
least 6 000 years ago by eastern brown
men and like literally one of the very
first verses of the bible says that god
made them male and female so the gender
binary is neither western nor modern and
so so funny when people think that we
can just like we can't see back also
isn't this like a bigoted point of view
like you know native american people
couldn't schedule or figure out time
like that seems like a horrible stance
to be like only white people know how to
like make appointments what are you
talking about the museum
the african american history museum
remember a couple years ago they put out
that like that page on their website
that was like being on time yes and
having lists and having schedules
delayed gratification yeah i had to tell
you i had to tell this guy i was like
dude
asians invented the compass 1000 years
before your ancestors did so don't come
to me and talk about how the white man
created everything because you just
you're a white supremacist you genuinely
think white people did everything right
get out of here with that stuff it was
it but that's their attitudes they're
like they're on the left and they're the
good people because they recognize that
they are the superior race but they
should be nicer to poor people it's like
get out of here dude i think that's such
a horrible stance today
that's their stance
i'm like this idea that you so when i
asked about this i when i said asians
have schedules bro yeah but that came
from colonies colonization and i was
like what and he's like like the white
colors came to china and east asia and
brought that with them and then i and
that's when i was like dude they
invented the compass a thousand years
before europeans did and gunpowder like
pretty sure they were doing their thing
before you got there that's crazy that
he thinks he's the not racist yeah
amazing algebra's uh arab yes yes
it means
yeah it actually means the reunion of
broken parts or bone settings
wow that makes sense that makes sense
it's cool yeah it's cool let's uh let's
jump to some domestic issues
here's a story
officials dna found at slain las vegas
reporters crime scene what is this about
well there was a democrat who lost his
re-election
his name was robert telus he was
arrested late wednesday for murdering a
journalist
because the journalist had been writing
stories about him that were negative and
it cost him the election now the funny
thing is you know the immediate
assumption a lot of people have is that
he did it you know and i'm like he's
innocent until proven guilty man come on
we don't know that this guy did it and
don't expect me to trust the journalist
in this story so it's like you got a
democrat is he the bad guy you got a
journalist who's the bad guy what
happened and i'm like i don't know
because i don't know what happened
like sure i think
from from reading this it really does
sound like in my opinion journalists are
probably lying about this guy
he was he so there's there's multiple
people in this race but he's writing
about this one guy over and over again
like obsessed with him numerous stories
that's just such an experience with that
strikes me as weird well yeah personal
bias i'm like what's the obsession
there's multiple people in this race
so why is this one guy you don't like
but i don't know for sure what i can say
is
for all we know this democrat had
nothing to do with it and he's just a
lead suspect for all we know he was
there but then he left and so they're
like you're at the scene of the crime so
you're under arrest for all we know the
journalists
was trying to stab him with a pen or
something i don't know yeah and he
defended himself i think we all agree
murder is not good we're not we're
against it um and of course innocent
until proven guilty i think
that's why it starts to be like we need
more evidence if his dna is found at the
crime scene how do we know it's his like
what is the context here uh the weird
detail about the story to me was that he
like arrived at his home in a hazmat
suit yeah which i was sort of like but
um that's a bold fashion and they saw
him doing it right they were like
waiting for him or something uh there's
a video of him in the suit and they're
like did you kill him journalists were
waiting at his home so like i don't know
who tipped them off or what the context
there was
but yeah that's weird but it's kind of
like what you were saying
earlier before we started recording we
keep hearing or we've heard for the past
few years that an instance like this is
going to happen on the republican side
it's going to be a republican that goes
after a journalist and kills them
because of all of
trump's you know anti-press
rhetoric and well i don't know if this
guy really did it but if he did do it
then that's not the case here it wasn't
the anti-press rhetoric from republicans
that caused this guy to possibly kill
the journalist right and if this
journalist you know if everything he's
writing was full of emotion and it's not
you know it's very biased and maybe not
factual like that's terrible reporting
and that is serious but you don't get to
vigilante kill him that's not how this
works either right right
i just
it's it is interesting that so many
people immediately jump to ah the
democrat and then i'm like well let's
see how this one plays out but there is
a very interesting point in that
donald trump kept calling the press the
enemy of the people the fake news was
the enemy of the people and then we saw
people like brian stelter i loved this
because he wrote an article three years
ago where he said trump falsely accuses
news organizations of fabricating
sources
and then a couple years later you get
usa today caught fabricating sources so
it's like yellow and apology but they
kept saying that trump's rhetoric was
dangerous it was going to get
journalists killed
and now it's actually a democrat being
accused of doing it so it's like is
there going to be an apology across the
board for the trump supporters who are
restraining themselves because
apparently yeah trump trump said um
that the the real opponent was the media
that they're running against because you
know it's not the democrats it's the
media so any any apologies or no yeah
they're going to keep pushing the
narrative that maga republicans are the
evil ones
are the the dangerous ones are the
threat when you have i mean this is in
line perfectly with antifa going around
smashing up windows destroying
businesses killing people
and then they ignore it and say yeah but
the trump support is the problem yeah
i've barely even heard about this story
honestly besides us talking about it and
seeing some conservative commentators
talk about it on twitter
um and so obviously if this were a
republican we'd be hearing about it
constantly we'd be seeing tears and
quivering chins on cnn like oh my
goodness it's so difficult for me to
come to work every day we already saw
aoc say in gq that she doesn't even know
if she's going to be alive in september
and so
there would be journalists saying the
same thing and they would say this is
the cost of republican extremism but now
it's barely a peep well we talked about
the other day aoc saying she didn't know
if she's going to be alive what do you
think she meant by that
i think that she thinks that the same
people who
apparently put a dagger to the throat of
democracy on january 6th they're going
to come kill her in her apartment before
she can you know zip away in her test we
talk yes if await her tesla
those things go fast uh we talked about
it too but i think there's a possibility
that she's depressed oh i think so i
think she deals with really serious
insecurity probably but also
this like insufferable arrogance which i
don't think is the exact opposite of
deep insecurity i think they often go
hand in hand
and to me she seems like um
she's unsure of herself while also
trying to kind of present herself as
totally sure if that makes sense yeah i
posited that she is maybe going through
a transition in her beliefs and she
can't transition
she
yes that's what i'd like to suggest i
mean she just got engaged this year
perhaps talking about having a family
and now she is uh
maybe having to face some of the
consequences of the policies that she's
pushed maybe she doesn't feel that way
and she's become the figurehead for i
don't want to bore everyone who's
listening especially specifically tim
and you made me hear me make this pitch
last night but like she was the poster
child for this liberal green new deal
pro feminist
squad that would be amazing if she
changed i think that she can't leave
politics and she can't reverse her
opinion well which is i
i don't like that for politicians so i
think that she was whether it's in her
head or real it seems like she was
really shaken up after january 6 like
she's talked multiple times in
interviews about how she's gone to
therapy how she's like she was scared
that she was gonna get raped scared that
she was gonna get murdered and like she
talks a lot more now it seems like than
she used to about like men and how she
feels objectified i do wonder like that
whole big booty latina thing that
happened with alex stein like her fiance
literally did nothing just like stood
there with their little dog like i do
wonder how much of like a stable force
he is in her life and if he actually
makes matters it's kind of worse for her
to have like a weak man by your side i
don't know we should do it
we should do a skit about
dr aoc and mr republican aoc or whatever
where she like drinks a formula and then
starts turning into a republican like
her dress turns from blue to red and
she's like
then she's like wearing a trump hat
that'd be awesome
[Laughter]
the alex stein the big booty thing where
he approached her on the steps i'm kind
of sad about the way it has has been
playing out because i feel like it's for
alex uh cortez that she could
totally just laugh with him and laugh
about it and like what dude come on he's
like a comedian guys well that's how you
get he might even run for politics
someday like it could work out you know
he's not like he's a really smart guy
and he has a lot of compassion and it
was very unfocused for a while and he's
starting to hone it in
and i would love to see them smooth that
over and well that's serious see
she didn't know how to handle a troll
right alex stein knew what he was doing
he and he he has this really great bit
i watched a video of him recently where
there's people protesting him and he's
laughing saying i love you you're
amazing this is so awesome i'm so
honored that people protesting just for
me we made it guys this is so big that's
how you handle it because they're trying
to rile you up if aoc started laughing
and she like winked at him and then
waved it would have all blown over
mm-hmm it would not have been effective
did in the video which is why it was so
funny she kind of was like oh haha funny
and then she
made the video like exactly adding all
the adjectives to her butt that like he
did not say
juicy like juicy luscious like he didn't
even say that maybe that's why she did
it she's like he's not he's not actually
reporting no no no she's it's it's it's
like it's like a an insecurity thing
where it's like he was he said my booty
was luscious
and juicy and i'm mad about it i'm
really mad i work out and i'm mad that
he noticed
i i think that aoc is this interesting
study in
someone who doesn't have a clear path
forward like i think
she has a lot of ways she can fall from
this cove position and i think she's not
good at dealing with trolls or negative
feedback because she has been celebrated
for so long as this like iconic young
democrat latina and like if those are
things that you're proud of cool
celebrate them but i think when you come
from
the opposite end of the political
spectrum when you're more conservative
like you
often are in a position where you think
that you are going i mean i'm sure this
has been true for you in your careers
like you're in spaces where you are
often the enemy right you're often the
wrong opinion and you get used to sort
of having to let things roll off your
shoulders if you are in a circle we're
competing for praise you know you have
very few people who are probably saying
like i i don't like what you're saying
she probably a lot of people were like i
like her saying but i'd like it even
more if you said this i i i gotta say
i could not imagine this the stress she
probably deals with it's probably
unbearable i can't imagine because we
know how awful it is
on the left when you're dealing with
canceled culture so so i have a friend
who is uh you know he's a lefty guy and
he was saying that someone he knows and
has worked with is getting canceled
right now for a wrong think or something
and then he's like do you think i should
criticize him call him out too or should
i just try and keep my head down and say
nothing and i said
i think
it's insane that you choose to live that
way yeah but a man so this is a guy
who's he's on the outside he just
happens to like he's in he's in an
industry that's woke and he's like this
is how it is so do i join the mob or do
i hide from them imagine being at the
epicenter of the mob like aoc and
everyone's constantly glaring at you
with darted you know evil eyes waiting
for you to say the wrong thing she
probably doesn't know what to say half
the time she's probably like sitting
there sweating bullets terrified that at
any moment it could all be ripped away
from her by cancel culture you think so
i i have a hard time believing the left
would turn on her i mean unless she went
like full maga
i mean she's a lot of really stupid
stuff and the left has never been like
maybe we shouldn't be putting her on the
cover of that she got attacked she got
attacked when she walked back her stance
on israel and palestine when she
initially did when she initially got
elected she got asked about it and they
were like you said something that you
know israel was an apartheid i can't
remember exactly what it was yeah and
then she was like well i should probably
look into that a little bit more and
they started relentlessly attacking her
saying like how could you do this you're
you're going cardboard being on the left
is like you're constantly in a
precarious position like you're
constantly walking on eggshells always
like so imagine being surrounded by
zombies yeah and you're pretending to be
a zombie and if you slip up they're
coming for you yeah but imagine being
on the pedestal with every zombie
looking at you
you can't screw up and she has to have
an answer for everything that has to be
the right answer i mean that is a
tremendous amount of pressure well
especially when she can't she's really
not i'm not just trying to be like like
troll her like she really isn't a very
good talker like she really doesn't talk
very well she has a hard time talking
and so i can't imagine
maybe maybe that's why maybe it's
because she has to overthink every
single word that comes out of her mouth
i don't know i don't know i mean i what
i said the other day was you know what
if you know she's getting married what
if she wants to not run for re-election
she wants to start her family and she
wants to be in new york for her but can
you do that when you are the champion of
you know feminism and like you know
women at work like she could be
influencer she'd probably make a lot of
money i mean i think i wouldn't i
personally wouldn't care i wouldn't
think less of how what she you know i
think she would be as committed to
whatever ideology but i could see other
people who feel like she is the example
of the young
successful professional who was a
bartender and she hustled she got to
congress and you know whatever she's
doing and if she says like
my family life is more important to me
than politics and this career like there
are people who i think would really drag
her for that and i can't imagine having
to
you know
weigh my personal choices as it reflects
on a larger ideological movement it's
not just drag her i just wonder who's
behind her like the people who first
chose her and put her up and are pushing
her to be this like representation of
like the future revolution i feel like
she probably has a lot of pressure
behind the scenes that we don't i just i
think she must get it from all
directions and even though i don't agree
with her the majority of the time i
would argue to say almost all of the
time i still have a lot of you know
i just i would hate to be in her
position in some in some respects it
must be
uh unbearable at times yeah i think
about
i don't want to turn people off from
running for office because we need
people good people in office but how
horrifying it would be to serve on the
bridge of the death star like they're
they're creating where do we go to war
next where do we send the military
machine on earth who do we kill who do
we defend who do we kill so that we can
defend what where do we get our lithium
where do we get our oil where do we get
and it's not all congress but
i mean that that stress on top like real
i think that's part of this red pilling
you said that you feel like she's having
some sort of mental resurgence or like i
just wonder i speculate like once you
realize that you're like the bad guy and
that we're like our government has been
the bad guy for like 70 years and
there's a lot of bad guys we're all
pretty much a bunch of brutes beating
each other in the playground is like
what governments are on earth up to this
point but it's not like you're not going
in to smile wave and then you know sign
some legislation so that everyone gets
their food there's not enough food we
don't have enough food for everybody or
if we do it's not organized properly
that's why people are starving in places
i kind of feel like though that she's a
narcissistic sociopath so i don't know
if she actually has those those feelings
and i know that might be like
i'm not trying to be hyperbolic or you
know like overtly demonize like i
genuinely think the things she's done
signify that she's a narcissistic
sociopath
like she lied about what happened on
january 6 she totally fabricated this
insane story that made no sense the
timeline didn't make sense you know the
story where she the guy knocked her door
and said where is she yeah that she she
said oh i think they like she she
implied the rioters got to her and she
was scared of that but at that point in
her story based on her own timeline the
capital had not even been breached it
wasn't breach until an hour later yeah
so she just literally fabricates this
whole story yeah for and then what kind
of person is willing to do something
like that
because the thing is
she she's she's been caught she's been
caught she's exposed for doing it and
she still doesn't care
because
she's got her cult little cult cultists
who follow her and just believe what she
says yeah i don't know if i would call
it narcissism i think about humility and
pride and it's not being humble isn't
self-hatred being proud isn't self-love
necessarily um what is narcissism like
excessive self-love to a fault yeah that
you orient everything around you which i
i would agree with the narcissism piece
i don't know if i would say that she's a
sociopath unfortunately i just think
that people
are bad people without having some kind
of like psychological diagnosis i think
that she just thinks about herself it
seems like constantly which is part of
why i think she's really sad like and
and part of the reason why she can't
take any criticism really because every
time someone criticizes her for a
totally valid reason she turns it into
this is an attack on my identity
no one's ever criticized her they're
only trying to date her exactly yeah i
was gonna say remember when she went to
florida with her boyfriend and people
were like wait this is like again
lockdown protocol and she was like stop
trying to date me it's crazy i mean
that's something that a narcissist would
say most people even if you didn't think
it was fair that's not where your mind
would go
yeah let's let's talk about actually
walking on eggshells we got this story
steve bannon charged with money
laundering and conspiracy so as much as
there may be some stressors for the woke
left because they might get canceled i'm
sure they view that stress as preferable
to being targeted by the doj for
what well you know i'll be careful here
i am uh reluctant to trust the doj or in
this instance new york states it's the
southern district actually not this is
new york city this is leticia james i
don't trust any of this stuff i don't
believe them sorry been there done that
russia gate ukraine gate get out of here
with all this nonsense now they're
criminally charging bannon
again because he was just charged with
contempt of congress they're they're
going nuclear against the maga
republicans
i expect it'll get way worse yeah i i'm
curious if you guys think they'll indict
trump before the midterms
hmm before the midterms i don't know
i don't know i think they will indict
trump i don't see what all of this would
be for if they weren't i don't know
about before the midterms maybe i don't
think they'll do before the midterms i
just feel like it's not going to move
fast enough um
but i will say that i think leticia
james is just a very clear example of
judicial activism i think that she very
selectively picks and picks her cases
and uh
you know has a clear agenda which i
would not want if i were a person from
new york as my attorney general so what
would you call it if at the federal
level at the state level democrats are
taking positions of authority in
prosecutors offices in part uh in the
da's offices in um
in the federal government in the in the
in attorneys you know they're getting
jobs as attorneys and judges and stuff
like that and then they're using that
power specifically to target their
political rivals
lock them up shut them down take away
their rights like what what do you call
that what's going on it's like
corruption or something it's crazy just
corruption
corruption is not a strong enough word
i think
what is
challenging for a lot of people is that
this is part of the strategic
strategic installment of sympathetic
people at certain levels of government
so
if people are interested in influence
elections you could say you should run
for office but you could also say you
should work at the polls you should be
in this county position you should do
whatever and i think that
the placement of prominent democrats in
offices of attorney general was
something that
most people wouldn't think to do because
they think it should be not a
non-partisan position right they don't
think we should put someone who has a
certain political agenda there we should
put someone who's a really good lawyer
really good at the law um i just i just
mean would you call it fascism
no it's not it's not that i mean fascism
is an element in authoritarianism what
we're seeing is that
ideologically driven democrat types
are intentionally infiltrating these
offices like the soros prosecutors
to get their people out of jail and to
put their opponents in jail it is some
kind of subterfuge yeah it's a
subvertive
cronyism maybe yeah i mean but it's it's
i don't want to say civil war i know
everybody's getting ready to drink
because it's not quite there but it's
something close to that where a
political faction is weaponizing the
government to shut down their political
opponents and their political opponents
are just sitting there and taking it
well on msnbc the other day a
commentator said the civil war may have
already started that's right well they
didn't really specify exactly what they
meant by that they were commenting on
biden speech but that's a little
frightening only one side is really
fighting
exactly and that's the funny thing
fox news and newsmax had this
incredulous attitude like the left is
talking about civil war oh silly it's
like are you watching what they're doing
to your presidents yeah yeah they're
sitting there saying it's happening and
and we're doing it kathy griffin
basically admitting the democrats are
ready to start a war and then the rights
going like there's no civil war
and have fun in prison but uh i i guess
the good news is we'll be gulag cell
mates so you know we'll have to we've
been saying that for a while but you
know i kind of take back
my answer on whether or not they're
going to indict trump because i do think
that a mistake that republicans are
making right now before the midterms is
to constantly talk about trump
constantly talk about what the democrats
are doing to trump i'm not saying we
shouldn't talk about that for the reason
that you just said
but that really doesn't resonate with
most people who are watching fox news
and newsmax most people who are not on
twitter they do not feel like we're in a
civil war even if they see things like
this happening to steve bannon or to
trump they're not thinking this is
probably going to happen to me one day
what i think resonates is the radicalism
that is coming from the left coming from
joe biden and their agenda and the right
is doing a really bad job of talking
about joe biden they're focused so much
on trump when honestly a lot of people
don't want to talk about trump they
don't want to hear about trump i think
they also get lost in like the fact that
joe biden seems so sick and ill right
like you don't want to make fun of
something like they feel sad for them
well it's like they don't want to say
anything that's like
too
gauche like they don't want to say
anything that was like obviously kind of
cruel to make some someone fun of
someone who's like in decline but like
joe biden does not seem well but i think
they're material in their policies
the way that the left focus solely on
trump the person the man the president
like that's what they think they need to
do to abide and it makes them
uncomfortable but what actually they
should be doing is examining his cabinet
and who else is in there and what else
is going on like we are focused on the
biden administration and making joe
biden the face of that that we forget
that there are other people and i think
when uh corinne john pierre came into
office like we're all sort of like wait
what this is your your pick like
trembozaki was like you know pretty good
like she was good she was good and this
is who they followed up with so you
should have questions about every other
staffing decision in the world i kind of
feel like jean-pierre doesn't actually
do work like before the press briefings
she's like watching reruns of friends or
like the office
and then it's like oh i got to do a
press conference then she goes out there
i remember there was at one point peter
ducey asked her a question and she goes
i don't know that i remember that
happening and it's like that was like
does that mean that they are not telling
their own white house press secretary
what's going on so that they can be like
just deny it like you don't know what do
you think she's that seems like a crazy
girl it's in look i'm sorry it's insane
to care about a white house press
secretary even as jen sackey or kaylee
mcinney or otherwise because you can't
expect the press secretary to know
everything
and to be completely honest i don't care
what party they're with there's like
there's no way no they're that's their
job their job is not to be honest no
it's not exactly it's it's so it's why
is anyone bothering so everyone's like
oh peter deucer peter ducey asked that
tough question
what he might as well have asked a brick
wall come on what's the point but i
stand by like what's going on with your
body's cabinet why don't we talk about
them more i feel like i hear nothing
about it well the right does but again i
think that they're i don't think they
talk about enough squishy well i mean i
think that we talk about what we might
get kicked off twitter if we say like
the hhs secretary is not the woman that
he says that he is and i mean there are
different things that i think the right
says maybe not totally effectively i
don't know if republicans in office do
though they don't seem to be i kind of
feel like if if someone was running as a
republican and they just like went up on
the debate stage and were like my
principal issue is
no sex change surgeries for children
what say you opponent
and let them be like i'm in favor of
that like okay
can i go home now yeah because regular
people aren't getting that framing
they're hearing health care yeah health
care gender from trans kids and it's
just like
just you got to keep going be like oh no
i agree with the health care thing for
sure yeah i i do i definitely think
trans kids are real and they need health
care i just don't think the sex change
surgery is appropriate for minors do you
god i saw a picture of a girl who got a
sex change surgery had her a double
mastectomy she's like 13. the red head
yeah oh my god in her eyes
you got to find this picture too maybe
on the after show we can pull it up yeah
and and the sadness in her eyes after
the mastectomy but so also 13 like what
are we doing
i mean she looks really young so i wanna
i wanna point this out too you know at
risk of pissing off youtube
we just talked the other day about
tick-tockers who are feigning terminal
illnesses for likes we know for a fact
that instagram is making young teenage
girls depressed because they don't get
enough likes
do people not think
that they think that those are isolated
from
social uh um
what's what is it um social contagion
gender dysphoria what are they called
rapid onset gender dysphoria yeah now
now i we i talked with uh james lindsay
and billboard chris and i i've said i
think you know trans kids absolutely do
exist i think
endocrine disruptors hormone disruptors
probably play a role in this but i think
a lot of what we're seeing in the news
and with these families a lot of these
kids are undergoing social pressures
from social media to to to
cave into this and you've got a perfect
storm of
you know a young kid going through
puberty dealing with body changes
popular social media content supporting
transition and parents who also are you
know
falling for that salivating medical
industry that can profit predatorily off
of these young children absolutely
disgusting the sackler family if you
look into what it was a dope sick and
they're pushing of uh oxycodone on the
population knowing it was addictive and
telling everyone it wasn't getting the
fda to sign off mocking people in rural
areas where they were pushing this drug
in their emails to one another these are
the people that are doing this to the
kids it's not not the sacklers i'm not
saying but it's people like that that
want profit over everything else now i'm
just pausing for like and looking at the
news article we have pulled up and i'm
like how did we segue from steve bannon
being charged with money laundering to
trans kids
that was a fast what were we talking
about i'm trying to think about what the
connector
well we talked about the ag and then we
like we talked about uh putting your
ideologies they're weaponizing and then
we talked oh
i got it i got trump indictment they're
talking about that before the midterms
you said that they should be talking
more about the people in their
administration i said well you can't say
that some people in their administration
are not the gender and then we kind of
got on to that they are creating though
if we're going to stick on the whole
trans kids thing which i would not agree
with tim that there is such thing as a
trans person i i just wouldn't there's
people with gender dysphoria there's
people that are confused there are
people that you know cross dress
whatever but anyway they are creating
lifelong slaves to the medical system
because okay you do a quote-unquote
gender affirming hysterectomy where you
take out a young girl's uterus and her
ovaries oh well great now you need to
freeze your eggs now you're going to
have to use a surrogate and have to go
through all of these different fertility
treatments in order to have kids one day
if you want to and so they are lifelong
medical patients and of course the
medical industrial complex likes that
it's all connected we've got two stories
here that i want to i want to talk about
the first is from kutv
utah utah-based zion's bank ops out of
participating in boise pride festival
this was over child drag shows and
zion's bank issued a statement saying
when we sponsored this we did not know
that they were putting minors in these
kind of situations and then boise pride
says oh miners have always been involved
and it's like that doesn't that's not
better
but this is interesting because it's
showing that a corporation is saying
we're going to lose money if we go this
route so let's not do it but at the same
time we have another story game gaming
charity games done quick
cancels florida event citing covet and
don't say gay law
so
i don't know what is this
florida is losing games done quick
because of they wouldn't have masks and
because of quote unquote don't say gay
the parental writes an education bill
that's a false statement don't say gay i
like to call that bill they don't say
straight because it has the same effect
and then over in utah we're seeing a
bank
cancel their support for a pride event
so i i don't know it's just it's is that
at first i was thinking the zion's bank
thing was a victory for the cultural
right in that companies are finally
being like hey that's the line for us
and we won't do it but you're also
seeing companies pull out of florida so
it's kind of like maybe it's just the
culture is bifurcating why yeah i think
it's bifurcation why would
banks
be putting money into gay pride all
kinds i mean like they sponsor it and
then you see their logo and you're like
i need to get a mortgage and i'll go to
that bank and the same reason they would
sponsor like a half a marathon or
something like that just i genuinely
it's for profit it's because they're
trying to get exposure yeah not
necessarily because they like it
although it's not because they're trying
to sew division or anything but i wonder
what happened like what happened with
zion's bank where they were like hey you
know sponsoring the sexualization of
children probably is bad for our bottom
line you know what i mean i'm sure they
just got a bunch of calls
yeah and i know i know idaho power did
too according to chris ruffo they also
yeah they also made a similar statement
i think it's a win for the cultural
right because what you're talking about
about that gaming company they've been
doing that for a long time they were
doing that a few years ago different
companies the ncaa did it when they
wanted specific bathroom
whoa
whoa
boise prides it's postponing child drag
show due to increased safety concerns no
i think it's because they're losing
money yeah see that's what they do it's
the same thing with the children's
hospital they turn it into see now the
story is not that children were involved
now the story is at the right is so
extreme and so radical they're
threatening so violent that they are
threatening the safety of children the
story is now
conservatives pounce and not that hey
we're enticing your kids to drag shows
this is always what they do i highly
doubt they're afraid for their safety
it's it's dangerous to think that
prevent attempting to prevent a child
from getting experimental surgery is the
danger when right the experimental
surgery actually could be considered
dangerous yes yeah well it's either that
or they're going to be like oh the
safety threat is actually coming from
the right they're threatening our events
so we have to shut it down it shifts
people's outrage it shifts people's
compassion they forget what people were
mad about in the first place and like oh
those memes
clever this is clever what they're gonna
do now
is they're gonna say zion's bank didn't
just pull out
they threatened us with violence yeah
they're gonna say the statement they put
out was stochastic terrorism
and now we're forced to shut our event
down zion's bank and the bank's gonna be
like we didn't we didn't mean it we're
so sorry this is this is war they
probably will backtrack yeah i mean i
think it's good though that they came to
pressure from the right i mean if this
is what it is then this is what it is
i mean i wish it would the headline said
you know uh boise pride pulls event
after major funder pulls out or whatever
and you can go into a backlash because
of child involvement like i don't know
that this is an accurate headline and
that bothers me purposeful right totally
purposeful and i think that probably
the way
that okay so
zion is probably a regional bank it
serves a lot of people in idaho i assume
maybe utah and people in those
communities don't like whatever boise
pride is doing they don't like the drag
shows right and in florida the gaming
company is saying we don't as a company
like this value so we're not going to
support here to me this is more
interesting the boise pride because it's
coming from the community people who
bank with this bank are saying hey i
don't like this i don't want to do it
whereas like i really don't think any of
the gaming customers i mean i would be
really surprised if the gaming customers
were like hey i'm gonna stop
you know attending your events or using
your service if you don't specifically
pull out of florida i think that is them
trying to pressure florida the same way
that the ncaa tried to pressure north
carolina uh when it said we're not going
to host um you know the ncaa basketball
i think it was like it would think it
was basketball that year
because that has a direct influence on
revenue it's a huge uh win for the state
i think you know republicans have a huge
opportunity in this midterm to have a
super majority if they campaigned
properly and i think the campaigning is
simple because a lot of people ask me
like how do i get through to my family
and friends they're too woke they don't
listen and i'm like
you don't argue with them
you feign interests like you know i
shouldn't say feign but like hear them
out and then you can simply respond with
yeah man you know trump he can be scary
but
i think the weird thing to me is all
these child sex change surgeries that
keep happening and then when they say
what do you what what are you talking
about be like i don't know i was just
reading something in like washington
post about children getting sex changes
oh my god that was weird show the
picture of the the 13 year old with the
no no no no no no
those stitches across the chest are just
this right that's that's level two the
first point is just to say this is
something that i find odd and then don't
fight with them don't argue with them
and if they're like i don't you're
talking about be like oh i don't know
here let me show you and then just pull
up the article on child sex chain
surgery and then be like yeah here like
they're whatever i don't know are you
and then and then genuinely just don't
be mean don't be like it's wrong and
you're supporting it both you got to be
like
i mean then you do what ian said you put
the picture and be like i don't know you
know look at this picture it'd be like
crazy that that i don't know i saw that
and i was just kind of like i don't know
what's going on anymore i had a i had a
guy a professor from st mary's on my
show and i had him on because he said
that the whole grooming thing us calling
people groomers on the left was a part
of an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
that had to do with q anon so i wanted
to have him on the show and ask him
about that
um and he claimed to be conservative
himself and claimed to be a christian
and so we kind of went back and forth
and i just like pulled up some articles
and was like do you support this here is
an example of a teacher ideologically
grooming a kid do you support like these
teachers pressuring kindergartners to
use they them pronouns and just like
make them kind of answer for that of
course you're not going to be that
bombastic with a family member but once
they're met with those kind of specific
examples and they have to answer for
their support he very quickly backed up
it was like well no no no no no and
tried to kind of narrow his opposition
once you can kind of make them do that i
think you can make them realize what's
really going on yeah i think part of it
you also have to hear like what you have
to hear past what they are using as an
example to hear what the concern is
right if you hear well donald trump is
terrible and he's aggressive and he's
rude and whatever else like if they
can't tie to example it's that donald
trump represents an ideology that is
different than what they're used to and
they're not gonna be receptive if you
shout back at them you have to
understand where someone is coming from
my dad gets really loud his name is also
tim and he'll be like donald trump that
guy and he's like getting loud and i'm
just thinking like
i'm so happy because he's communicating
with me that's all i care about at that
point i don't i'm just happy that he's
letting it out yeah you asked him why
he's so mad at trump next next time i
want to get deeper yeah last time my mom
was like oh kim you're getting angry and
he's like i'm not getting angry becky
i do think part of it is like people are
unwilling to have these conversations
because
we see uh discourse on uh things people
disagree about as so volatile most time
it's better not to have the conflict and
i think part of that is on you you have
to control how you react and keep
yourself accountable to being civil and
you know
talking with compassion as much as you
can about these issues while not just
compromising your viewpoint right like
you have to be honest about how you feel
i think so often people are afraid to
say like i actually don't agree with you
because they think the fallout will be
so bad and it doesn't have to be we need
more courage
you know i i i mentioned this before it
is not courageous for the people who
work here on this show to say our
opinions because we know we have a
company where our opinions you're
allowed to say right courageous is the
guy who works at a steel mill who speaks
up and says that courageous is the
person who works at a school who speaks
up and say and says it and uh it's tough
but we need more people to stand up and
just be like hey man
the child sex change thing is a line too
far like i ain't going there i ain't
voting for those people
i if you can't that's the thing
if if you as a as a regular old american
cannot publicly say
i refuse to vote for child sex change
surgery
then we're screwed seriously because
like like that story to me was just like
yeah that's that's beyond the line you
know like for me i voted for trump uh
you know in 2020 for a variety of
reasons that did not broach children
getting sex change surgery now we're at
that point where i'm kind of like how
could any reasonable person
who agrees with us keep quiet now
knowing this stuff has been happening
children young girls some as young as 13
getting double mastectomies yeah
i mean i can tell you unfortunately i
spent a lot of time on white woman
instagram and liberal woman instagram
which is the worst place on earth and
you would be surprised at the number of
like suburban
kind of conservative christian moms who
buy
this idea that well it is compassionate
to allow kids to do this because they
might commit suicide or i don't have a
say in this their doctors their parents
know best or who believe in like the
propaganda about not being able to get
miscarriage care there's a lot of
misinformation it's what we were talking
about like that toxic empathy piece that
i think so many women especially
christian women are just totally
manipulated by they're just manipulated
by the maxims that trans women are
wisdom women and things like that and so
i mean that's how they're drawn in fake
compassion toxic empathy it's pretty
easy to get people to believe anything
if you tell them that doing so makes
them sound like a good person you
mentioned toxic everything i think it's
fascinating did you do is that what you
wrote about in a book or was this just
something you've been focusing on well
that's yeah it's something it's not just
me it's something that a lot of i would
say like conservative christians have
been talking about for a long time
because there's such a problem of
progressivism within the the church and
it's this idea that we have to lead with
empathy we have to see with empathy we
have to discuss everything with empathy
i'm like look empathy has its place it
can be really good to be able to put
yourself in someone else's shoes but if
that's the only thing that you're doing
then you're gonna make really stupid
decisions because you don't look at the
facts you don't look at what's true you
are partial in your judgment making
you're deferring to one person over the
other because you think it's
compassionate to do so and it's going to
make you make decisions that have really
bad consequences like open borders like
social justice crime policies because
you're told that's empathetic they have
deadly consequences i think that there
are a lot of women and maybe you would
know more about this from your social
media stalking but i think there are a
lot of women who fear being bad moms and
doing wrong by their child and so it's
easy to then say like
well if their doctor says it's a good
idea to do this i'll just commit to this
lifestyle because i don't want them to
ever look back and be like you're the
one who made me suicidal you're the one
who made me depressed well sure and
abigail schreier would definitely say
there are people like that but it's more
the women who go along with it their
kids aren't involved but you know who
just go along with it but they want
their kids to have the friends well
they're more concerned about how other
moms see that yeah yeah
let's talk about the good news and the
bad news from timcast.com the
economist's midterm model shows
republicans have a 74 percent chance of
winning the house democrats have a 78
chance of holding the senate
kind of sucks huh
yeah
you definitely have to go vote is what
i'd say
people get so mad at me when i'm like
hey man a red wave is not guaranteed
they're like don't be a black pillar
don't be a dooms here i'm like oh i have
said it once i will say it again
i think conservatives can get complacent
and i mean conservative not just
republicans but libertarians who even
lean on the conservative side like
anybody who falls in this scope they can
be like well it's close enough we'll
just trust it's going to happen that's
not enough you have to remain more
active than that well i think a lot of
people are thinking like okay if
republicans do take control yes that's
better than democrats having control but
really what's going to happen are there
going to be a lot of strongly worded
letters or they're going to be more like
investigations that are televised like
what's really going to happen what are
republicans going to do strongly worded
letters yeah that's about what they do
they're really good at that yeah print
more money i think they'll just keep
printing money and ignore the federal
reserve yeah yeah that's sad that's what
we already feel like that's if all
governments but this is why they're
freaking out so much about the maga
republicans because the maga republicans
actually are going to do something
they at least do something yeah now the
of republicans who do you think that joe
biden is thinking of do you think he's
thinking of like marjorie taylor green
matt gates those kind of people lauren
gilbert
yeah
and uh well but also look at the people
who are winning right when liz chaney
lost he probably cried
yeah you know him and him and all of his
democrat buddies were like no you know
our our spy
yeah we lost her but she is on the
subcommittee she is supposed to get
reelected
it's like
liz cheney is effectively a democrat and
that says so much about what the
democratic party has become
like they're supporting this woman is
just but i think that speaks to the fact
that they
a lot of left-leaning people want uh
consensus they want people to agree with
the stances that they have and
the idea that
their
that true policy and governing comes
from debate with people who believe
differently than you do and whose ideas
are different than yours uh isn't as
easy to
build consensus around right because it
involves conflict this is this is
similar to what 538 has there 538 saying
70 out of 100 simulations show democrats
winning the senate who connects this one
this is the economist oh okay okay and
think about how sad that is
that republicans were up in the generic
ballot and now democrats are back up the
republicans just don't know how to
campaign because no they don't
understand emotions
michael males made a really good point
that democrats voted for this guy what
was his name mel in 2000 the missouri
senator guy you want to look him up he
died what's his name and they look it up
senator dies and gets elected he was in
2000.
democrat
died and they still voted for the guy
and so he he was like republic
he said republicans going after
federerman's health are making a mistake
because they don't understand totally
democrats have literally elected a dead
man and then the governor had to appoint
someone and appointed his widow to run
way more often i mean this was uh
there's a podcast called missing a loss
that talks about uh alas the last
democratic alaskan senator uh or
congressman uh nick begich and then hale
boggs from louisiana both went missing i
believe they weren't declared dead at
the time of their election but they were
definitely missing no one like their
plane blew up no one knows where it is
to this day they both got re-elected
hellbogs's widow took over he ran and
took over his seat
this uh his name is mel carnahan this is
phenomenal i've never heard this before
tonight uh on november 7 2000 select the
next u.s center for missouri incumbent
republican senator john ashcroft ran for
re-election for a second term but he's
defeated by democratic governor mel
carnahan despite carnahan's death in a
plane crash three weeks before the
election day despite that
he died and then three weeks later
people hated the other guys so much they
still voted for the dead guy for the guy
who died for whatever reason come on
dude republican is party loyalty that's
intense
yeah i think that after the i think it
was the second debate between trump and
biden when trump just like would not let
biden
finish talking there was a lot of
sympathy i saw on social media for biden
it wasn't like oh he looks weak i think
people kind of wanted someone that was
weak which is really sad but i think a
lot of people do because of that
emotional piece well i think people get
the big criticism of trump is that he's
too aggressive he's too harsh and he's
moved too extreme so on the opposite
biden seems like this career polish you
know
soft-spoken uh incumbent he's old it's
because he's old and i i really
fundamentally believe that like it
reminds me it's a mistake
you know of their grandfather yeah you
don't want somebody yelling at your
grandfather yeah it's kind of cute that
he takes a nap at 4pm and he can't
finish his sentences oh
well and it makes him hard to attack
because if you attack him you're like
you're attacking my grandpa yeah and
you're attacking like an elderly person
like that's weird yeah he's nasty and
he's always been nasty yeah
um i
would love to see
republicans
see this poll
and become more motivated right
i think
a lot this is sort of a dangerous period
for conservative-leaning voters because
they'll be as
much as possible discouragement and
you'll see a lot of left-leaning press
say like well this this race has
basically become unwinnable and like
you'll read the article that'll be the
headline they'll read the article and be
like well i don't i don't really know
that that's true
i think
that the red wave is not a guarantee i
think that it's definitely something
that you'd have to stay committed to as
voters but i also think that like
they
the other side of the aisle would like
you to be discouraged i kind of feel
like when uh the republican primary in
pennsylvania was happening
donald trump picked up his phone he's
like i'm going to be giving an
endorsement to a great candidate and
then right when the phone goes up to his
head
a a a squirrel dropped dropped an apple
on his head he went don't ask dr oz vote
for him and then all of a sudden the
news press like the press runs with it
trump endorses oz and and now
republicans are going to lose
pennsylvania
thanks you think that that i mean i know
you don't literally think that's what
happened but i think it's like yeah but
i think it's very true i think it's very
trumpy i think it's very trumpy to be
like he's like you were on tv and i was
on board this is my friend like him and
hannity and dr oz have been friends for
a long time i think that is what trump
cares about far more than any ideology
and i will say that
oz has gained in the polls he's still
trailing but he's only like five points
behind fetterman now fetterman just
agreed to have a debate in mid-october i
mean like
i think
you know
maybe he can win it's like he could but
that's the thing like we feel like he
can't we're already counting
pennsylvania out and like i just feel
like it is too early to call even all of
this modeling you know
it will dramatically change so much
because we know the final basically six
weeks before the election can produce
some crazy changes did you see
fetterman's speech when he was bumbling
his words and saying the wrong stuff
like he had a stroke about a year ago
six months ago uh he had a stroke in may
and the day that he won the primary he
was actually undergoing surgery the guy
was messed up in the head right now he's
not equipped to run a state this is
freaking well so that's what pat toomey
said he endorsed oz before but then in
this recent coverage of like because he
at first um federer was like no i'm not
doing a debate like you guys are
bullying me and you are making fun of my
recovery and oz was seen as really
aggressive being like look if you want
to represent the state come out and
represent the state
and then
recently pat toomey was like the thing
is if you're in congress you have to be
able to speak clearly you have to be
able to endure like you need to be able
to do this like it's actually not
unreasonable that there would there's he
would he should be understood it would
be reasonable you would step down from
congress if you suffer a mind-altering
stroke well they should give him a bell
that he can have on his right hand that
he can ding and then the nurse can have
a list of the letters i've been watching
breaking bad a lot so no i mean like
i mean part of like what's hard about it
is so the uh oz campaign sorry i wrote
about this for timcast.com so i'm up to
date on this one all right uh
the oz campaign had offered him they had
to like we want to do five debates and
we'll offer you all kinds of
accommodations you got an earpiece to
talk to your staff we can have more than
one uh bathroom break you can have
something to sit on like and the
bathroom like seems kind of insulting i
think it makes him feel like he's
geriatric and he was like no you guys
are like you guys are not respecting my
you're supposed to be a doctor and
you're not respecting my recovery it's
serious i'm getting better i'm getting
stronger but like this is insulting and
they held two the oz campaign held two
was like no you should have a debate
like it's traditional this is not i
think pennsylvania's been having debates
in the senate race since 2016. yeah uh
and
the oz campaign hasn't committed they
said it's gonna be mid mid to late
october they won't say when but it's
this this back and forth we're like oz
seems aggressive and i think a lot of
republicans are like please stop don't
do that but the other hand they're
producing results i mean he is getting
this debate which he said he wants well
he was on the defense i feel like oz was
on the defense for a long time like they
were trying to do funny like twitter
memes and that's just not going to work
it's snooky fetterman had snooki in one
of his campaigns which was funny new
jersey that was really that was yeah and
it was funny like fetterman's social
media strategy has been good and he has
been most sorry but he's been mostly
virtual while he's been recovering from
a stroke right which has been good and i
think it's good that oz kind of decided
okay that's not going to be my game it
has actually kind of pressed him because
if you're not strong enough to debate
you're not strong enough to lead the
state
i feel like
fetterman is more likable than dr oz
yeah and he's america's coolest mayor
says the guardian right you you take
politics out of it like i don't like the
democratic party and i don't like most
of the republican party but you take
politics out of it and you've got a dude
who's cracking jokes and wearing a
hoodie and then some doctor in a suit
talking about crudity and it's like
i don't know man i think that that's a
big factor because people voted for
barack obama because he was a celebrity
people voted for justin trudeau women
did because he was a hunk huh that was
was like a pole or something came out
right like the women were like they
voted for trudeau because he was
attractive must be canadian women well i
think a lot of people vote for
candidates because they're attractive
didn't trudeau do like a weird yoga
thing on his desk or something and then
trudeau is weird
he's a weirdo um but that's what gets
you votes man yeah well and also like
they have this hometown boy versus like
no i mean no no no no i'm not saying
that i'm saying he's more he's more
relatable for sure but he's been i feel
like he's been seating this i mean he's
lieutenant governor he's been prepping
for this race for a while uh he was
celebrated during cove but he did a lot
of stuff that people in pennsylvania
supposedly liked he was making the
rounds with his wife on like different
relationship podcasts talking about
their marriage and stuff like that uh
you know i i think
he has tried to prepare to be the most
likable candidate obviously
unpredictable that he had this stroke
right no one really could have seen this
one coming um but i do think that
he was the guaranteed winner of the
democratic primary for a long time which
made it much harder to calculate who he
was going to be up against and
the
i think the hardest criticism that i
hear of oz is that he's maybe from new
jersey or something and that's maybe not
enough for pennsylvania voters and he
was like
pro
transiting the kids a few years ago
maybe not pro but he platformed it on a
show and he was anti-second amendment so
that was my big that was my big thing
also i didn't like the primary against
kathy barnett when he had all of these
like republican trolls coming out
against kathy barnett and just straight
up lying about her for the sake of all
he has been running a super aggressive
campaign it's wild you know regarding
fetterman's rise to power what he's been
doing he's been working at this his
whole life he's been aiming at this his
whole life i have compassion for someone
that is about to run the race of their
life and they break their ankle but you
don't run the race in those situations
if your ankle's busted i have compassion
but not to a fault like what you're
talking about earlier that's dangerous
if you want to love some ill person and
let them run your life you're going to
die that's that's the result you have to
make the best healthiest person in
charge they've they've elected dead
people yeah they've literally we are at
a breaking point this is
this is it this is the moment when the
world is looking at us to lead i um
you know in in in a hard
idealistic sense i actually think voting
for the dead person is the better thing
to do because then you have no one in
that chair screwing everything up the
problem is in real life
they just appoint someone to fill the
seat so you're voting for nobody you're
voting for the governor to just be able
to put in whoever they want which if you
live in a state where the governor's in
your party and you trust him is why you
would do that right so if you are in a
blue state and your democratic person
dies or goes missing and you think that
the governor will appoint another
democrat to fill the spot like yeah you
cause you cast your ballot along party
lines i love that meme that's uh you've
probably seen it says vote nobody
nobody supports the people nobody cares
about the working class
nobody will fight corruption nobody
cares about you vote for nobody that's
right and it's like that's a great meme
there you go yeah but you know it's a
bit jaded i think we've got some good
maga republicans who are uh who are in
congress who are running
are you a fan of uh marjorie taylor
green forcing the floor votes that's
such a fantastic move i tweeted this out
and i wonder what you guys think do do
you need political zealots to run a
government
no
what do you mean do you need in order to
find in order to run a government to
have a government function do you need
political zealots involved people that
you don't love politics that want to
politic
officer in america i don't think someone
who is unwilling can
sustain the lifestyle right but i also
think that we forget we see the elected
official and we forget that they have
advisors and staff and other people who
are helping write their policies like
there are a lot of ways to be involved
with influencing uh politics in the
government you don't have to just be the
person on the poster re-election bothers
me because people shouldn't be in and
thinking about their next term that
should never never even remotely be part
of it they should just be allowed to be
what if they get in they do the job
they're four years and they're out or
eight well well what if they're really
good and you want them to come back
thank you start a business and i'll
follow you on instagram but what if i
thought they were putting out good
policies and i want them to stay keep
talking about your policies on twitter
and i'll follow you but you're done in
politics after that but then you create
shadow governments we already have
shadow governments we're making them
worse i don't think so man if you want
to say
this is a we have a government here and
that you're a governor of people's minds
then yeah maybe
but like there is power to social media
and socializing and getting cults of
people to do what you say
maybe what happens is you know like
someone gets elected to a first term
right
and then we don't have to worry about
reelection because we just make it a
lifetime appointment and then you gotta
you gotta worry about what happens after
that well simple we just have whatever
position they had transferred to their
children or the first boy oh that's
perfect yeah there you go and then you
know geniture and then you don't got to
worry about re-elections and then what
we'll do is if they don't have kids we
eliminate the position and then you know
eventually it's gonna make everything
way easier yeah there's just one person
who inherits the we'll call it a throne
and then they're in charge and then when
they die their kid takes over and just
one person this is novel i wonder what
no one has thought of that yeah super
simple it seems like and then no one's
gonna worry
no term limits none of that just there
you go i think i want my politicians to
be thinking about their reelection i
want them to be thinking about their
next term don't do that i'm not going to
vote for you i want them to be scared i
think term limits if you have term
limits and they know that they're out of
office no matter what why do they have
to listen to what their voters or
constituents want why do they have to
care because they want to survive after
they're out of office you're saying
people will attack them oh well kelly i
didn't say that if you go into office
and you betray and destroy people's
lives you better run for your life i
mean you're that's not a good position
to be a human
i don't want the consequence to be look
at the issue of humanity congressional
approval what's the congressional
approval rating 17
no one likes these people well i'm
talking worst case scenario if a leader
goes in and rapes and pillages his
population they're not like look at
libya look at what they did to muammar
qaddafi i don't want to but i don't know
what i'm talking about airstrikes i'm
just talking about hillary clinton i
mean there are already politicians that
go in and betray their constituents all
the time if they don't get killed list
cheney is out of office but she's not
dead well they're not really
i mean
they're not betraying people i don't
think the politicians have really
i mean
maybe maybe them siphoning off our
wealth is a form of betrayal but yeah i
certainly think i don't feel like well
they're making things worse it just
doesn't feel like they're making things
better i want to talk about a cultural
issue before we go to super chat so we
have one more segment this is from
podcast movement yeah heavens they've
apologized to ben shapiro saying as we
stated we're continuing to evaluate our
policies guiding social media and events
with inclusivity diversity and respect
for all we have to start by sincerely
apologizing to mr shapiro for our
reaction when he visited a booth we sold
his company that wasn't right just just
think about how insane that is yes we'll
sell you a booth you show up to said
booth we condemn you showing up even
though you paid us and we knew you were
coming to me so i can respect them now
for coming out and uh saying the right
thing and apologizing to ben they say it
began in 2014 when four podcasters had
an idea to create a community blah blah
we're now looking to move forward as we
focus on that original mission from 2014
being a hub for podcasting events okay
you know you know what look i respect it
you know always give respect to what
respect is due they said it was wrong
they're apologizing to ben shapiro fine
daley wire why don't you just create a
podcasting convention they probably are
already working on it yeah be real
jeremy's podcasts stop giving money to
people who hate you do another
commercial and then we'll get a booth
there too that'll be great we'll do a
podcast there yeah but don't call it
podcast because that's an apple thing
the ipod yeah you know xerox
yeah a show just a show but it's like a
broadcast specific a broadcast maybe
yeah yeah that was really weird i know
what you're saying but i also don't have
the right word because podcast has
become so specific in our vernacular
broadcast comes from when they used to
cast seeds when they would plant a field
they'd cast broadly they called it a
broadcast and then it just kept in the
vernacular until all of a sudden so we
could retake broadcast isn't it weird if
you think about it though like the the
the launch of podcast people at ipods
and then someone was like i'm gonna make
a talk show to put on your ipod and then
like all of a sudden people were
listening to these things it's just
something that apple's like we're gonna
get their minds but then when like
spotify was like we want those two they
had to keep calling them podcasts they
should stop but dude like again what's
the alternative shows this is called the
vodcast yeah video video on demand cast
that's right
so we uh
forget apple are you a vodcast too yeah
i'm a vodcast wow yeah i don't i don't
call it that i call it a podcast yeah
but so like rogan's is called the
vodcast this is a vodcast
vlog like a video vod means video on
demand so
it's like it's not a podcast like
podcast was on ipods and now these talk
shows are video on demand podcast dude
that's it that's what it's called yeah
these are vodcasts now
but that's well they're also shows i
like show because it's one syllable the
show could be like a theater like i'm
almost thinking it's too non-specific to
be like come to our show convention like
are you putting on theater performances
are we going to the movies talk show
talk show but if you're talking about
someone who doesn't know and then what
do you do i have a podcast you wouldn't
say vodcast right they'll understand it
yeah
i guess
coming up with a new word i like do you
think we could definitely come up yeah i
don't like google is a verb either i
don't like that these corporations are
in people's minds i don't do that
anymore i don't
search it yeah i say bing it
duck duck go in that's right search it
on google if you want so the point the
reason i brought this story up was not
to debate words in semantics but to
point out another culture culture war
victory and they named it they said
bench peers specifically by name i think
that that's shapiro it could have been
very easy to be like we're sorry if any
of our actions upset someone no one in
particular though you know there's a guy
why they did this like why did they
apologize you know there's two there's
two ben shapiro's in media there's
probably more to be honest but uh the
editor i think the editor of vice
magazine his name was ben shapiro
literally ben shapiro yeah and when i
worked at vice
ben shapiro and then he was like at the
time this was back when ben only had
maybe like 20 000 followers or something
and so it was funny because people would
mix up the two ben shapiros i don't know
what he does now though but you know
clearly one benchmark
benjamin shapiro yes i'm pretty sure he
does yeah yeah i wonder if there are
others you lost your name like imagine
that imagine like that's it your name is
like john smith or whatever you know
let's say let's say your name is you
know i don't know something more uh
weird ian crossland yeah
and like um imagine like when you're
coming on the show ian there's another
dude who's like got a master's degree in
like he's like a master a chem he's got
he's got a phd let's say phd he's
actually doing graphene research
experiments and he's going around
talking about how much he wants graphene
and then everyone's like oh you're that
graphene ian crossland guy he's like
yeah i am from that podcast that hippie
weirdo no no i'm the phd sorry you lost
your name someone else is now more
famous than you with the same name so
but they're then contacting you and
being like tell us about your experience
in your doctorate program and you're
like what no that person wouldn't exist
and that other guy is to go by like ian
jamin crossland now
should we get rid of names and just use
numbers then
yeah that works
yes be a lot of them i see 74316. what
is your opinion on graphene i was going
to change my name to ian like prince
or cher i was about to man i was going
through a midlife crisis i didn't do it
anyway my point is i guess what i was
trying to get to why do you think
they're they're they're backpedaling
yeah i don't know it just seems like
they're under digress or something it
feels like the right is getting cultural
pressure
and companies are now realizing it's not
worth it did you see what christopher
ruffo tweeted about disney
registered voters disapproving of disney
now they're underwater i guess
like no no their approval rating among
voters is 51
among independents it's 47 among
republicans it's like in the 20s or
something
surprising to me actually not me
like have you have you seen the latest
stuff they've been producing i have that
won't go broke
i'm always surprised at how much people
are paying attention i guess
yeah but i kind of feel like
it's watching disney is the the
definition of not paying attention you
know what i mean yeah if you're trying
to watch
marvel
and then they they show you she-hulk
twerking or something you're gonna be
like okay hold on a minute
like i'm not okay with whatever it is
they're doing yeah and then all of a
sudden
you're political
you know jennifer lawrence wants
everyone to be political well she's
afraid of tucker carlson she's she's
having time and probably right now she's
having a nightmare about tucker girl
said poor girl so strange but here's
what i said they said they said she had
nightmares starring tucker carlson it's
like for all we know her nightmare was
like aliens are abducting her oh and he
saved her tucker has got like an iron
man suit and he saves her
probably disturbed her
does that mean that she watches him
regularly for him to show up in her
subconscious yes
that's what that's true like i would
never have a dream about chris hayes
because i've never watched a show right
right what if she's like hate watching
them every night yeah they say like
sometimes people that you see on the
street or like you interact with in a
restaurant will come will be your
subconscious because your mind remembers
their face right but she's seeing tugger
carlson so frequently she can identify
him in her dreams like that's i think
actually telling us like what's going on
at home
they're they're not like they're not
nightmares
they're they're actually amazing i
imagine she's not you know you have a
nightmare you know you wake up in a cold
sweat no no she's having
beautiful
fantasy dreams where she's on the right
on the back of a stallion and tucker
like you know he's like they they trot
up to like a beautiful waterfall with a
rainbow and birds of paradise and then
she goes oh hold me tucker and then he's
like you're so beautiful and then she
wakes up just like normally with her
eyes slowly opening goes
okay that was a nightmare
that's it yeah she's actually having a
deep fantasies i'm supposed to not like
that right okay then it was a nightmare
not a beautiful experience a beautiful
experience
she's only calling it a nightmare
because she doesn't tell people she's
dreaming of tucker carlson she does well
she's got to go on
like she just told us that he's hanging
out in herself
i learned from the best in media thank
you brian stelter headline jennifer
lawrence has recurring dreams
about dr carlson or about jennifer
lawrence constantly is constantly
dreaming about being with tucker carlson
boom there we go yep i wonder if she's
in the dreams with him i got to know
more i want to know about i want to know
everything about these dreams just tell
me i want i want the whole
it would actually be funny if the dreams
were like she walks into an office
building and tucker's a receptionist and
he's like just fill out this form sign
here and go to the third floor and then
she's like ah like what if it's the most
banal and mundane experience she's like
in bed and her husband is like secretly
watching crosstalk while she's asleep
and that's what it is he's like hearing
her voice and so she's like seeing him
in her dreams but actually like it's her
husband's like i'm a closet conservative
when i when i would go to sleep watching
adult swim
i would have scooby-doo dreams all the
time and i was like constantly in the
mystery machine you know with with
scooby and it was it was funny because
like scooby and shaggy would be saying
things and then in my dream i'm like
responding to them but they weren't
talking back and it was the weirdest
experience and then i would slowly wake
up and scooby doo is on you know that's
that's probably it that's it that's what
happened it's her husband he's he's a
huge joker carlson fan
he's like yeah we're going to bed no
problem like you you lay down she's
having she's mean she's like having a
dream where she's like driving in her
car and tucker sitting next to her going
and now the democrats want to want to
steal it you know it's like i agree it
might be feel very strange to suddenly
have tucker calls and like lecturing at
you in your dreams but especially if you
think you don't watch him but you
secretly do liberties are very weird she
said that she became a liberal from
watching 30 rock yeah i did see that one
but but she said lemonade
was that was a republican well yeah i
don't know which part of 30 rock made
her a liberal i don't think it makes any
sense at all
also she was like i watched it when i
was like 13 and you want to be like
you're super grounded in your political
opinions yeah
liz lemon in 30 rock goes into i can't
remember who's office and she says that
she tells her friends she voted for
obama but she secretly voted for mccain
that's funny she was a secret mccain
voter maybe that's what she's trying to
tell us you can be a democrat outwardly
but you can hide it you can actually
vote for companies yeah like like secret
trump supporters that's what she but the
crazy thing that's why she watches
what kind of person voted for john
mccain it's interesting because
a large portion of the current younger
trump supporters are not fans of john
mccain at all yeah like warhawk
warmonger
but liz lemon did and she's
liberal
she's further right than most of the
trump supporters to be honest i don't
know i don't know what a weird way to
become liberal
i watched a show where i was 13. yeah
i became an anarchist because i watched
how you met your mother you're like what
what does that make any sense who said
that oh i'm just making it up right
that's one way to become an anarchist i
realized that life was pointless yeah
i became uh uh a nihilist from watching
big bang theory
because i realized people actually like
this stuff oh my gosh big bang theory is
so not funny it is the least funny show
i have ever watched in my life have you
ever have you ever seen it when they do
um they take out the laptop
oh
oh
so comfortable
and it's like what happens is like dude
walks in and then he's like what are you
doing and the guy goes i'm working on my
thesis and he goes just like a fibonacci
sequence
but like there was i remember watching
one where he's like that's my favorite
fibonacci number and then there's like a
laugh track and i'm like where's the
joke yeah
dude i don't i mean
it's off the air now okay
yeah is it
i think so i think so it was like a big
it was like hot but it was like i mean
people like the show
i don't think i think they feel smart
because it's like some science words in
there and so they're like oh yeah
science hey look i think 30 rock was
fantastic i like 30 rock yeah they're
russian my husband and i both like that
are you now a democrat because of liz
lemon i'm that's why i came on the show
to tell you
i am i am coming out as a liberal
because of liz lemon yeah cool there we
go all right everybody we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have that extra
fun members only show coming up at about
11 p.m let's read what y'all have to say
we got daft end who says woke leftists i
don't believe you can call yourself a
libertarian and have any respect for a
monarch let alone one who raised and
protected a son allegedly worse than
hunter biden
uh i disagree
i can say i don't like monarchy i don't
like the queen but i still think that
you um
you don't win win friends with salad is
that the saying
salad yeah you don't win friends with
salad remember that's true that's that
the old saying i had no idea that was
there the point is there's rabbits
everywhere
you don't walk up to somebody who's
mourning and gloat and laugh at them and
tell them how evil and stupid they are
and how awful they're like that doesn't
that's not going to win you you know
when your friend's over
but um
you know i guess i i can say criticizing
the sun and the actions of the parent
are are
i agree with that actually what's up
what are they talking about prince
andrew yeah oh he worked with epstein
didn't he do stuff with absolutely that
absolutely
that's one way to put it it's a gentle
phrase i also don't think i think
there's probably no one on earth who's
uh immune from criticism and again you
should criticize your government shaky
own says this is for ian to get a
thesaurus ian we're literally going to
use that to order you a thesaurus and
then we'll put it on the table yeah it's
function but i have one on my computer
what's the word you need
um give me another word for um
what's how would you describe prince
andrew
um
can't say it on youtube yeah i was going
to sell this okay what about hunter
biden crackhead is there is there
another is there a synonym for crackhead
i bet there is a substance enthusiast
you're welcome alternative subject
that's a good one is that junk junkie i
mean these are all chunky sniffer sniff
taker
he's got that from his dad yeah hunter
sniffer smack head that's a good one
well that's joe sniffer by me from his
dad it's weird how it works both ways
well there's junkie with an ie and
there's junkie with a y really different
words huh dope
polaris says i was kind of bummed to see
michael malus decided to send out so
many tasteless tweets about the queen
including one about inbreeding i'm not a
fan um but you know as a mature adult i
don't agree with michael malus on every
single thing he does but i'm still a big
fan and he's a good friend so it is what
it is you know i'm not i'm not i don't
like reveling in death i just don't like
it you know when it's like a terrorist
or something
i'm willing to go so far as being like
that was good that we stopped this evil
person and you know that's fine it's
another thing to like
i don't know just gloat and mock and
post pictures of people mourning their
loved ones because you disagree with
them politically yeah like i don't think
you need to mock anyone's family members
when they're mourning but i also think
it's like it's weird how people are
saying oh so it's okay to mock this evil
person's death but not the queens okay
but a terrorist and hitler those people
aren't the same as the queen you can
disagree with the queen but like we're
not moral relativist the things that she
did weren't as bad as like terrorists i
think it's okay to celebrate a terrorist
death i don't think it's okay to
celebrate the queen's death because i
don't think there's the same kind of
person yep
tony deadgrave says i didn't know pop
culture crisis had a political show in
the evening this is great that's right
um
so you know basically pop culture crisis
which covers the the the news and
information that most people actually
care about
realized that there was still this small
niche market of politics that most
people don't care about that's why they
hired you i think that's right that's
right so we're doing this show but the
funny thing is
i am 100 confident that in like a year
or two pop culture crisis is going to be
bigger than iro like it's a pop culture
show and then you're going to add money
guns for people to shoot money at you
it's going to be all driving i'll retire
i'll be like brett it is yours brett and
mary you make the money right now is
like no
brett does an amazing job but he really
really gets uh
i don't know how to say other than
anxious yes yes oh man it's pop culture
christ so it's i mean it's kind of
obvious though they talk about you know
movies pop culture actors and stuff this
is the biggest stuff in media right now
pop culture is politics
but that's not going to be forever at
least i don't think so i don't know but
i genuinely believe that people are more
likely to watch something about britney
spears i mean case in point britney
spears and elton john topping the charts
number one that kind of stuff is going
to do better and i think he and mary
complement each other so well their
interests overlap but also are you know
in their own space they really do a
great job of like getting what you would
expect for pop culture and then
something you're not expecting i'll be
on it tomorrow pop culture crisis
the 200th episode i've heard it's the
200th episode of pop culture crisis and
brett mary i love you too but brett man
that guy
he's just like um an encyclopedia of
popco of cultural and popular media
knowledge it's really fun to talk to him
about stuff
and orange sea lion says we dumped tea
in the harbor to stop talking about the
monarchy let the lotus eaters handle the
monarch shout out to carl benjamin in
the lotus eaters podcast um we did a
little bit more than dump tea into the
harbor i think we shot a bunch of people
too and like burned things down so it
was a pretty complicated process and
foreign intervention and all that stuff
but here's the deal man i don't care for
the royal family's drama i don't care
for the meghan markle stuff that's
nonsense but the queen dying is like
massive news and there's a lot of people
in the uk that i like and respect that
are you know feeling sad over this and i
think i don't get it but you know i res
i try to empathize i would say too i
believe there are people in uk who do
not love the monarchy in its current
state and maybe have never liked it who
also know that this
is a huge turning point for their
culture they are really saying goodbye
to an era of history that they probably
have complicated feelings about we're
not saying the monarchy is all well and
good but you have to recognize that this
is much more complicated than just some
old white lady dying
dana burke says the royal family is not
your friend charles is a world economic
forum member and publicly advocated for
the great reset multiple times look it
up tim good vibes ian yeah i'm not
saying i like them i'm just saying like
when john mccain died i said something
like neutral to slightly nice about him
you know i don't like him he's a warhawk
but i said something like it's he's a
man who truly believed he was serving
his country
you know and that's even tough because
i'm not even 100 convinced but i'm like
i'm not here to dance on graves not at
all i i just don't but
nobody like there there's a meme from
the political compass memes where
every political quad every quadrant was
celebrating the death of john mccain and
the centrists were like you know rest in
peace
and i was like yeah guys man people
really did not like that guy yeah but
that being said
that photo that the libertarian party of
new hampshire posted of megan crying
over the coffin was just so unnecessary
absolutely wrong so unnecessary you
could criticize him i don't care about
criticizing him even after he died but
why post a picture of his daughter
crying that's just cruel oh man yeah not
a fan no like dude
the guy had his like
there's a lot of things that autumn i
don't like for sure
but his daughter come on man guys
i don't know though it's tough staying
true for the queen's kids they can all
be terrible but we can recognize that
this is a huge moment in history i would
not celebrate if something bad happened
under biden no or joe biden i'm like no
i want i want joe biden to live a long
well as long as he can comfortable life
in his wheelchair with a burlap you know
a little blanket on his lap in a sunroom
as he as he doses off i want hunter
biden to get the treatment he needs to
deal with his problems and to stop
doing whatever it is he's been doing
with his illicit dealings just just go
away go be happy go live your life key
point you know
yeah just go away
we don't want we don't want no we don't
need bad thing we need good thing okay
good thing they can go have something
else and then we'll try and get things
back on track
mark va says ian check your history
please the british empire ended in the
40s with indian independence elizabeth
was never empress of anything it ended
with her father
is that uh a technical if that's a
technical thing then just send me a link
on twitter um so i can examine the the
technicalities of it but everything what
i was reading was that it was very vague
about the kind of the phasing out of the
empire roberto lara says shinzo abe
gorbachev and the queen have left the
2022 chat this heiress chapter is
closing and we still have three months
left winter is coming god save the royal
corgis
i do want to know what's going on with
corgis like where are they now yeah i
thought about that earlier too
i want a nice picture of like william
kate and other kids hanging out with all
the coordinators i bet they have a plan
for them but they're not going to the
pound i'm sure
christopher casimir says currently at
fenway park boston seeing aerosmith live
and listening to you guys at the same
time keep up god's work love you guys
and aerosmith well that's cool how are
you listening to both that sounds fun
prepared yeah that sounds pretty fun
performa says hello new york viewer here
kathy hokel is losing ground after going
against the scotus ruling on concealed
carry lee zeldin is within striking
distance thanks for another great stream
vote
go door-to-door
register people to vote
you gotta do it man democrats have
organizational power yeah oh it's their
their biggest strength that they are
good at organizing people republicans
got to go knock on doors
and then you got to bring flyers and be
like will you vote against child sex
change surgery
that's right this is the candidate who
opposes it
or
you know
a more
palatable issue i guess
gun rights or something but you know i
don't know i just think people probably
would say i don't like the idea that
children get sex chain surgery i like
the idea that you invite all this was
yours from a couple shows ago uh you
invite all your friends get pizza and
say you'll drive but then you stop by
the polling place on the way yeah well
yeah you know it's just like you know
real quick are you guys gonna vote but i
i wanna make sure i stress like
you know
when you're you gotta the pizza is an
aside it's just get your friends
together to go vote you know what i mean
like don't give your friends things for
voting that's you don't want to do that
no you want to ask your friends to come
out and hang out with you go vote and
you're saying like i want you to be able
to participate in the democratic process
i'm going to drive the polling place if
you're registered in my area come with
me yeah all my friends register your
vote thankfully
yeah just big voting parties everyone
gets together in votes that's right
all right let's uh let's grab what we
got here oh there's a there's a bunch of
comments about uh
israel the angry canuck says aj plus has
videos of americans kicking out
palestinians from their homes on youtube
for all to watch china isn't kicking
people out of their homes wow
a canadian defending china
and criticizing israel
yeah but and i'm not like trying to
counter what you're saying but we got to
be careful just because you don't see it
happening doesn't mean it's not
happening and china the chinese
government's very good at blockading any
kind of media of what's going on over
there
and we did happen to see some video in
israel so i don't want to just pin all
of it on them because that's what i saw
it's not saying it's good but
frumantari says france still has an
empire of 46 000 square miles of
overseas territories territories from
colonial days
crazy the uk is the pitcairn islands
right that's uk it's like 50 sounds
right
50 people who live there and i think
there's like accusations of pedophilia
and inbreeding or something
something like that
all right tom b moore says good evening
tim and crew fresh conspiracy someone
swatted the irs building in memphis
tennessee today looking at the available
news multiple multiple reports of an
active shooter still nothing found after
three hours of searching and evac
huh jeez no idea
memphis man
had a rough go of it
kadius says crowder's new song
definitely doesn't sound better than tim
poole but that song rolled a solid 20.
which one was that was the nancy pelosi
one i don't know but crowder crowder
does song parodies like you know it's
kind of like political weird out weird
he's political weirdo yeah yeah like
we're just making content you know we
just we're making songs that's about it
grim pickens says man i'm just shocked
that ian spoke more than 10 words
without mentioning graphene or central
banks really i did mention the federal
reserve pretty early on oh man
i'm not wearing a graphing shirt today
okay what do we got oh i just learned
last night that graphene itself can
produce an electrical charge no way just
through thermal motion what defies uh
what's it uh the brownian
i don't know if i'm going to get that
right or not
when did you become interested in
graphene i know this has been a
long-running thing 2011. okay and how
did you find out about it i think i did
a blog about it a friend of mine
actually andreas nicholas used to work
at tim cast was uh putting graphite i
think he's painting graphite onto cds
and then putting him in a cd burner and
using the laser to etch off graphene i
don't know how i was making it and i i
was doing like science blogs with minds
so i came across all this new cool
technology in like 2011.
andrew ho says tim you never read my
super chats but i have also been a team
cast member for some time watch the uk
go ultra ultra awoke now with king
charles iii and the world economic forum
pawn new prime minister
yes agreed
but i mean many people were saying the
queen was woke anyway yeah she was
letting it happen one of the big
criticisms i've heard is that she gave
up a lot of conservative traditions over
time yeah wow
carnivorous libertarian says aoc
constantly talking about wanting to date
her
fake tears of 1 6 and constantly wanting
the spotlight is very indicative of
insecurity and arrogance
you well you know what i think about aoc
is that she was a bartender and more
power to her i don't care that she was
but i think she fears going back
hmm
she's terrified of going back
well
it's possible at this point though she's
a prominent activist she'll write a book
you know what i mean yeah she'll get a
spot somewhere yeah
zoro zoroark graft says japan also has a
monarchy
very interesting a lot of countries have
monarchies
yeah sweden does spain
justin clark says all right tonight
tonight's in i'm really rooting for
operation red pill aoc sensei prager
should teach should reach out and offer
her counseling imagine how powerful her
why i left the left video would be
it would be i would want to yeah she'd
be like i decided to have kids and be a
mom and then everyone got mad at me and
they told me in the board for her i feel
like i could be friends with her if she
moved into that stage in her life
well there is there's numerous studies
showing that having kids makes people
more conservative of course it does yep
ain't getting married
yeah isn't it like
what percentage of women say they're
that have kids say they're glad they
didn't abort the kid is it like 99.9
extremely high
i know that i gotta look it up though
it's kind of weird you know we have a
family of deer out in front of our house
and they're always just doing deer stuff
yeah and it's just like i can't imagine
a deer
intentionally killing its own baby isn't
that weird
they did there'd be something like
mentally wrong with it there's a deer in
my neighborhood that adopted two
uh fawns whose mom died and so now
instead of having like two babies she
has four and like the whole community
knows about it dude we have like seven
deer they're like they're just on the
lawn you know every night when i go back
there's like just like seven deer and
they're all just staring at me as i walk
past them and i'm like hello dear
and then they just go back to just
eating and i'm like where do they sleep
but earlier today the baby was sleeping
just like right outside the bush and we
could see him chilling he's like looking
around doing and then the mama deer was
like walking right up to the house it
was pretty funny that's sweet 95 of
women
95 you looked at the actual number yeah
university of california it says 95
percent of that
yeah honestly i'm worried about that
that means 5 out of 100 women or like 1
in 20 women are like
having a kid and looking at it being
like i should have aborted this thing
yeah that's crazy i really hate that
that number's too high man that's crazy
we should have a study that studies that
why do you feel that way what's wrong
with you oh i did some research on the
brat hope experiment there's more to it
than how we've been describing it oh
yeah yeah you electrocuted him too he
found domesticated rats would swim he
took 12 domesticated rats to start three
of them were floating on the surface
went under the water to search around
drown the other nine just swam for two
days they don't know why so then they
got a bunch of wild rats all 12 of the
wild rats drown immediately so they're
like why these domesticated rats
lived for two days so they figured it
was because of their social community
and their support system before they
were put in the water so then he
realized i think it's hope and so he
would find rats dry them off put them
back in and then he would get the uh
there's even more precursor
interesting so he gave them hope and
then they tried to survive
that's creepy man
dreamweaver says i'm from kentucky usa
and the news about the queen hit me like
a ton of bricks she symbolized so much
about the old generation her passing is
truly a turning of an era yeah i
completely agree it's the end of an era
seriously i felt that about like george
h.w bush and john mccain dying too like
politics aside i i do see their deaths
as an end of an era that represented
better people generally than we have
today and that makes me sad
all right ben busher says the podcast
wasn't invented by apple they bought it
from adam curry one of the most based
mofos on this rock you should have him
on 100 uh adam denied that someone i was
tweeting about it and they were like
adam you created the pod thing didn't
you and then he responded no
huh if that's part of his sale agreement
he has to say no no he's always apple
i don't know
jacob barney says tim with shows and
record label i'm wondering if you'll be
expanding to publishing books next as a
writer who puts my beliefs in my in my
writing i'm worried that any future
publisher may try to change my story for
the woke yes
yeah
you already published like shane's stuff
right yeah so i mean we have we have
another book coming out tales from
inverted world goes to the civil war
which is based on the show you guys
really should watch it on timecast.com
but um
yes we're going to do all that basically
all that means is we like give you money
so that you can live while you write a
book like in advance yeah so we'll get
we give an advantage that you can write
the book and then we sell the book and
then hopefully make enough money back to
pay ourselves back and then make money
for you
but we're not there yet
so
the same thing is true for the music and
the plans of the label and all that
stuff we're starting in-house with the
music we already have here because we've
got a handful of musicians already tons
of stuff we have to produce but we
definitely want to find some outside
talent that needs
some some uh you know
i don't know funding and resources to
help get the ball rolling marketing
really
marketing man that's the real benefit of
getting with a label as they market you
do they really a good one
the thing is tim cast with this show has
a marketing apparatus so
if we were to like release a song once a
month then we could just be like hey
guys the new song is out this is a band
that does this here's who they are and
that's more than most labels can do for
you i was thinking last night about a
record label contract and like i would
love to build a contract that they they
still use in a thousand years because
it's so good for the artist like a
springboard like like that's the best
diving board on earth all the greatest
divers in the world trained on it and
now they're adults and
they remember that that company that
launched their careers and then they
start their own labels and do the same
for other people like you make them more
famous and more in control of their of
their career and then you're always
remembered as the great for doing that
one of the greats
kyle says the banks and corporations
sponsor pride events because it helps
their esg score this is something you
need to bring up more because that is
causing much of this that's true yeah
yep
maximus rita says are the eldians from
attack on titan britons my people
yes
i guess
sure
uh and if you're a fan of jordan
peterson you got to watch attack on
titan
okay yeah i don't want to spoil it but
it's like a lot of what he talks about
is exemplified by what that show is
although like the first few seasons
you're just basically watching giant
people eat little people and you're like
i don't know what's about but then later
on when you realize the backstory you're
like oh man this really is like right up
jordan peterson's alley very political
stuff interesting concepts
the sins of the father etc
quick pause 555 says tom mcdonald drops
a new video tomorrow at 9 a.m pacific
time it actually looks really cool you
see the ad that he put out for it riot
his like hands are glowing or whatever
i'm excited shout out tom mcdonald we
got him to uh chart on itunes by
shouting him out so
let's um
we gotta we gotta we gotta make sure we
get tom mcdonald on the billboard charts
so we'll uh we'll shout him out all week
make sure that happens so tomorrow at
9am guys
watch for tom mcdonald's song buy it on
itunes if i don't know how he's
launching i haven't talked to him about
any of this stuff but uh let's just see
if we can help get tom mcdonald riot
billboard hot 100
everybody just buys it for a buck or
whatever it is he sells it for then dude
hits those charts and they they can't
ignore it anymore that'd be awesome
ry lyon says poll came out showing 20 of
democrats and 36 percent of white
college educated women believe men can
give birth ah tough college is going
well i see yeah it's totally worth all
that money
all right
raymond g stanley jr says irl gets so
many viewers we all need to step up yes
right on man right now
this is the crazy thing you know it's
like on each episode across the clips
and the show itself it's like a million
and a half views
and i'm just like can we get a million
and have people to all just buy for one
dollar tom mcdonald song
because here's my point like i'm of
course proud of the music we're putting
out i would love to see a million have
people buy our song but it's not really
about that so people are like you know
on the left saying tim's grifting he
wants to make money off people i was
like okay don't buy my song and then buy
tom mcdonald's song then you give him a
million and a half dollars i mean a
third of it go or like 10 is going to go
to the net networks or whatever i'm just
saying we need to take over these
cultural spaces he's got a song coming
out tomorrow how do we get every single
person who watches this show to just be
like okay okay i'll spend the dollar to
help tom mcdonald that's how you change
the game
make tom mcdonald rich so he can keep
doing this and he can work with more
people and he can get on those lists and
then the media is forced to cover it and
talk about what he's talking about take
over the culture man
so we're i'm definitely going to shout
out his stuff tomorrow when it comes out
and then you know following week for
sure
david murdock says check out the new
trailer for drag the dead at david
murdock art on the twitters a
third-person pearl clutching zombie
shooter with zane maj uncle hotep and
adam kriegler demo right around the
corner ps counterculture will require
curation where's the platform
interesting cool what is that drag the
dead is that a video game interesting
third person pearl clutching zombie
shooter cool stuff
shout out
eric miller says that would be a good
cast castle bit have someone that looks
like aoc from behind wearing attacks the
rich dress she drinks a vial and then
it's steve bannon in the dress still
screaming text the rich
james o'keefe yes
all right let's grab a couple more super
chutes
david j art says does britain join the
eu considering the queen interesting no
because she's uh the head of state not
that of government so would still be up
to the point but without her is there
now no
but liz truss was a uh she's a prime
minister and she was brexit so oh okay
all right then well i guess not
i guess not
let's see we got here in the old super
chat
super chats
publishing books we read that one what
do we got here
jamie mcdonald says hey tim and crew did
you know that the scottish gaelic
meaning for donald is world ruler
potential meme magic is that true
look that up i don't believe that
donald means world ruler
that cannot be true in what language in
scottish gaelic
world wielder is that yes
celtic
donald means world
ruler or world wielder yeah what does
trump mean where's that come from drumpf
yeah what a drum for me it came from the
word trumpet i think so what i have is
that it's from
the male given name from the celtic word
meaning world trump came from trumpet
yeah hold on look that up yeah that's
what i wanted what's the police social
media platform trumpet it is trumpet i
don't know let me like no no come on
fact check that so they're like the best
trumpeters on earth no no drumpf that
was the name of his grandfather and they
changed it to trump right
so what yeah so the word is trumpet yeah
english surname the modern english
surname trump so his name is literally
announcement of the world ruler yeah wow
[Laughter]
for real his name is world ruler
like
trumpet like declaration like parents
thought about that while they were
naming him no no they didn't know donald
meant that are you sure though maybe
they did maybe he did his dad i know a
lot of parents who knows basically i
know a lot of parents who like look up
the meaning of their kid's name and
incorporate i think his dad talked like
him little donald jr is there a video of
what is it fred is that probably i bet i
bet so because i mean don junior talks
like him so but like
his name means like the trumpet of the
world ruler that's amazing world ruler
sound yeah the herald of the winter
ruler herald of the world ruler yeah
sorry
so say harold the winter mist maybe
that's why they're so scared of him yeah
like they know his name his legend is
foretold
but then donald trump jr is the same
name yeah yeah what is what does junior
translate to like originally we know
it's like the second son or like the son
of or whatever
i mean baron means young warrior
baron means young warrior yeah like
what's the literal meaning of junior
let's see i know we have our you know
contextual meaning of what that means
the younger one it means the younger one
nickname for the most part really yeah
well then his name is include it can
mean lower herald of the world ruler
younger yes the younger herald of the
world ruler
wow man that's it see in the future
that's crazy dude oh yeah trump comes
from triumph things like that triumph
triumph trump
the victory of the world ruler is his
name wow
i have no idea that's what donald trump
wow dude marion holtzman says people are
cruel no humanity left even for the dead
well you know people like us still exist
and uh people like you marion so you
know we're trying to to be nice and keep
some some of the hostility down my
friends if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends if you really love it and head
over to timcast.com join us become a
member we have a members only show
coming up at about 11 p.m you don't want
to miss it you can follow the show at
tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast ali beth do you want to shout
anything out
uh yeah you can follow listen to
subscribe to my podcast relatable
wherever you get your podcast it's also
on youtube you can buy my book you're
not enough and that's okay anywhere that
you buy your books i'm on social media
alibi stuckey you can check me out on
those platforms
i'm here claire brimlow i'm a writer for
timcast.com i think you should go there
every day click on the retab and read
stuff from me and the rest of the news
team you can find me on instagram hannah
claire.b and i know ian's going to shout
it out but i really think you should
watch the who the 200th episode of pop
culture crisis tomorrow at three o'clock
you should really you really should
watch that 100 it's gonna be hot i'm
gonna be there and uh i want some pop
culture crisis tomorrow three o'clock on
youtube and uh go to cass castle on
timcast.com and sign up to watch this
week's episode every tuesday we're
putting out a new episode i thought was
really funny it's getting better too the
cast is amazing charles you were crazy
that was great
really happy to be a part of it looking
forward to more see you later i am
really hoping that the 200th episode is
when we finally get to see brett forced
to cut dye his hair blonde i'm very much
looking forward to that was it 15 15
crisis parties in one episode brad has
to bleach his hair
i don't know how i got him to agree to
this it's very important to me that this
we have to do it 100 let's make it
happen ian's on tomorrow it's going to
be a good time i'll be on next wednesday
it's always fun over there as we all
know politics is downstream of culture
that is why pop culture crisis is so
important you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sourpatchlids as
well as sourpatch let's stop me we will
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you